[Music]
hey guys welcome to scrub Master full
course video by simply learn in this
video we'll cover some of the most
important concepts related to scrum
we'll talk about what exactly scrum is
the components of scrum process the role
of a scrum Master the scrum methodology
how scrum meetings work how scrum and
kanban are different from one another
and finally we'll cover some important
interview questions that will help you
Ace your interview our instructors Jeff
and Chandra will help you understand the
topics with ease before we begin don't
forget to subscribe and click that Bell
icon to never miss an update from us now
let's Jump Right In hi
welcome to scrum tutorial from Simply
learn
I am CMR Chandra Mr a professional
consultant and Coach who is certified
scrum Master PMP Prince to practitioner
itl4 managing professional devops and
kobit 5. highest part of this tutorial
we are going to understand the basic
understanding requirements of scrum the
agile methodology
so let us look at a problem scenario
what was there in the absence of
adoption of agile in any given
environment
so in the given scenario there is a
problem expressed
so we have a problem our consumer
doesn't like our product we will have to
make changes immediately
so now as usual any manager would
respond the manager says make the
changes
so because it's always the changes or
anything what we deliver is in the
consumer's interest so keeping consumers
interest in mind the value it needs to
be created for customers any changes
required to be done in any of our
projects involving that consumers and
customer we may require to do the change
so but what is the problem here to do
the change so we can't we already have
started work on last batch
the waterfall model we follow doesn't
let changes to be made Midway through
the process so is it mean the waterfall
model never allows the changes to happen
that is not true 100 percent waterfall
model allows us to make changes but it
doesn't allows us to make the changes
quickly so whenever there is a change it
requires lot of effort
it requires changes in documentation it
asks for the changes in various
different implementations which has
already done which is executed already
and then a lot of efforts are involved
which is time consuming and also it
involves more cost
now how do we make the change which is
required to the customer and at the same
time we don't have any specific
additional effort which are required so
these efforts whatever is being put is
acceptable to both the parties both the
stakeholders that is the project
organization as well as the customer so
how do you make it happen quickly as
well that is very important for us
so we should have used the agile
methodologies so meaning agile
methodology helps us to do this so one
of the agile methodologies which we are
going to look at as part of this
tutorial is Scrum so let us see how
scrum is going to help the scenario so
scenario of changes which are coming up
more frequently right
all right so before that let us
understand what is the meaning of agile
what is the meaning of agile what it
means and why should we adopt a jet
so agile means moving faster being
flexible responding to the changes
now agile is a set of methods and
practices that focuses on iterated
development why iterative in each
iterations agile methodologies helps us
to create a working piece of the
software product which will help us to
make quick corrections to those software
piece there's not a whole product it is
part of that bigger product
so requirements and solutions are
obtained
thanks to self-organizing
cross-functional teams collaborating so
when we say cross-functional team
self-organizing team so these are the
teams which are 7 plus or minus two the
size of the team what I'm speaking about
who basically have various different
skills each of the team members will
have various different skills and they
complement to it I think today the
devops is speaking about this
cross-functional team owning everything
as a single team some of the
organizations has already demonstrated
their devops capabilities by having this
approach like having self-organizing and
cross-functional team having an
accountability for the entire product
the particular piece of the product
module what they have created so this
helps in improving accountability and
also ensures better visibility of the
product what is being created and
delivered
so
further let us look at the advantages of
using agile so what it gives to us how
it helps so now the organization who
follows the agile methodologies so we
can see that projects follow a
predefined schedule and have a
predictable cost so schedules are seen
but wherever there is a change is
required wherever there is a directions
need to be changed in terms of making
Necessary changes to adopt to the
required scenario the change scenario
agile helps us it gives that flexibility
so clients have visibility of each phase
of project so it is very essential
whosoever adopts the agile methodology
the active involvement of customer has
to be ensured so they are actively
involved so customers or clients
actively involved in the sense they know
it what is happening what they are
getting they know they are acknowledging
it by giving the feedbacks every now and
then so that there is no surprise to
them at the end which used to happen
during waterfall approaches
then greater interaction between project
team and the project
means there needs to be collaboration
agile emphasizes on having the
collaboration so scrum in specific have
something called daily scrum where 15
minutes meeting where entire scrum team
should come in sit together uh
self-organizing team as well as all that
agile team has to come together express
what they have completed before the last
daily scrum meeting and what is spending
why is it pending and what is that they
are going to do before the next meeting
so all these are expressed this will
help the team as well as the scrum
Master as well as the product owner the
visibility into what is complete what
needs to be completed and this will help
project manager or scrum Master to
provide the necessary inputs better
visibility to the customers and
stakeholders as well
product output is predictable and can
sometimes happen earlier than expected
so now initially as we know so the
visibility of anything what we do will
be very less
so now as we discussed more and more as
we brainstorm more and more the
visibility into it will become more then
what would happen in future the ability
to predict will also become easier and
if this doesn't happen only with the
project team it also happens with
customers and every stakeholders who are
involved in the project
so next high quality development testing
and collaboration is ensured since the
project is broken down
so now each iterations each module each
piece of software which is being created
are tested regularly feedbacks are
obtained from the user as well active
involvement of user are ensured so that
they are acknowledging it so the what
customer needs are given so it is not
that I discover something which I did
not need I I'm seeing it I told
something I'm getting something that
scenario is eliminated
then the product backlog can be refined
and re-prioritized so since we move
iteration wise depending on the change
scenario depending on the directions
changes we can keep reordering or
re-priorising our product backlog what
needs to be created first if have one
two three four five item I can make it
as three four one two five
so depending on the change scenario
whenever it needs to be executed it is
bit flexible and easy to do
then teams can maximize project value
since clients can provide project
priority so as we know the visibility
also increases to the consumer as well
as all the stakeholders they will also
Express what is that value they have
seen from this and this will also help
in making a decision should we continue
with this project or should we not so
better visibility better decision making
better value realization
the needs of the customer can be focused
on increasing the value delivered so as
customer gives the feedback as that
visibility increases then a customer is
getting that value and then expressing
what is the changes what is that
additionally they may required here how
can make it better so these interactions
can happen so customer can be focused on
increasing the value delivery so in fact
I think earlier we used to speak about
time to market today we are speaking
about time to Value which means how
quickly uh the consumers the users or
customers realizes the value is that
benefit realized so that's what the more
and more discussion which is happening
which requires closer collaboration with
consumers and their feedbacks their
experiences with the products or
Services which are being used by them it
is very essential to understand
so then various different methodologies
what we have in agile we can speak about
scrum kanban extreme programming that is
XP lean methodologies the crystal so now
in this video tutorial we are actually
focusing on scrum so let us understand
what is this scrum is all about
right so before we go and understand
what is the scrum itself so let us look
at the history of scrum where it started
how it started So Right Down the Line
during 1986 the name scrum is first
introduced by the management experts
and Hiro takat kuchi so Japanese
so now this terminology introduced but
later in 1995 Jeff souderland and Ken
shiver creates the early version of what
would become the agile methodologies so
now earlier 1995 so need for agile was
sensed and it was spoken about I mean
why do we need a gel methodologies in
future what would be the Future
Organization which would look like so
that would trigger in terms of what kind
of approaches we may require to have
so further 2001 the agile Alliance is
founded and first look on scrum the
agile software development with scrum is
published
so then further down the line 2002 the
scrum Alliance is founded by zweber and
certifications are added
then later 2006 the scrum mink is
created the certified scrum courses are
taught so people started getting
certified on scrum
then later 2009 scrum.org is created
which offers the professionals scrum
series of certifications
then 2010 the first scrum guide is
published so which made available to
everyone so from then I think the more
and more people start adopting scrum
methodologies now interesting part is
the journey started from 1980s till 2010
various changes which has happened to
this particular methodology but one
thing we should keep in mind is same 20
years back or 15 20 years back if we go
the need for a jail was not seen so it
was spoken but need for a gel was not
spoken much but today we are speaking
about it more and more the reason is I
think the change in the market condition
the increase in the competition the need
of responding to the change which is
asked by the consumers or the market
variations has become more and more
important for organizations and service
providers if they don't respond to the
change they may lose out in the
competition so their survival is at
stake so it is very essential for them
to understand this Dynamics and respond
to those scenarios quickly so that's
where the adoption of agile the benefit
of adopting agile were realized and
scrum become popular
so what is Scrum so let us look at that
so now scrum is a framework that enables
teams to work together
means collaboration is very important
while we become agile
so with scrum team one can look I mean
see and experience so learning from
experiences happens so those are
captured
self-organize working on problems so
they work together they discuss
brainstorm reflect on their victories
means any achievements has to be
celebrated acknowledged quick wins
recognized and their losses to improve
so wherever the things doesn't go good
necessary Corrections has to be done I
think scrum approach would help in terms
of doing it quicker better
then some of the benefits using scrum
would look like steam can provide
project deliverables and in an efficient
manner so in time a we are completing
all the features and functionality so
the the entire model the methodology
what is there which helps in
accomplishing those
then further time and money are used
efficiently so time is very important
giving results in the mentioned schedule
is very important ensuring results are
coming up effectively is important
efficiently the performance of that
products now since we are creating those
small piece working piece in every
iterations
so that experience of using that would
also be there and quick feedbacks will
come back so that time and money is
saved
and we are doing in time so projects are
divided into smaller units called Sprint
so the iterations what I was speaking
about the quick iterations of activities
which happens uh during the adoption of
scrum when organization adopt the scrum
methodology so it is called as print
it's a time box iterations which will
have a set of subset of product backlog
taken as a Sprint backlog and those
users stories and pics are delivered as
part of that Sprint and then those are
reviewed on a daily basis as part of
daily scrum meeting and also we have
other meetings which will happen when we
go and look at scrum methodology how
this happens I think we'll get better
visibility
work best for fast moving projects now
whenever we need to respond quickly
whenever we want to move faster now
remember when we say moving faster means
it doesn't mean that we can allow any
defects to happen we can ignore
something we cannot do that we need to
ensure everything is taken care at the
same time all those results what are
created has to be acknowledged
right confirm yes it is defect free so
all those which is supposed to be
addressed are taken care and things are
moving faster and better and the results
are according to what was actually
expressed as a requirement it is
fulfilling those
then scrum meetings provide the team
great visibility since there is a daily
scrum meeting which keeps happening
people speaks about what they have done
from the previous daily scrum what is
that they have accepted they will
complete and what is complete is
everything is complete or something is
pending if it is pending why is that
pending and what is that you are going
to do further before the next daily
scrum meeting so these are discussed
understood so that there's a quick 15
minutes meeting which gives the insight
and further wherever there is a
dependency deviations which occurs
further maybe scrum Master sit with them
separately to understand that in detail
so daily scrum meetings give the quick
insights
so that it increases the visibility what
is happening on ground
constantly involves feedback from
clients and customers as I mentioned
earlier while discussing about agile
active involvement of customer is very
essential so customers should give the
feedbacks whenever that working piece of
the application or a product is given so
only then whether the product or that
module what is created is having that
features and functionality which helps
in providing necessary requirement
fulfillment is that happening or not
then making changes based on feedback
are very easy because everyone is
informed and they are aware of what is
being changed and what needs to be
changed
then individual efforts of the team
members are given Focus
yes individual efforts is essential at
the same time each team member cross
kills we call it a self-organizing team
as I was mentioning earlier so each team
member will have a different different
skills different different capabilities
and also cross killing within the team
is encouraged so that the ownership on
individual's deliverables and team as a
whole working together to deliver some
features functionality can also be
accomplished right
then scrum team involves product owner
scrum master and then scrum team so each
of these are different roles having
their own objectives to accomplish with
the specific directions and each of this
cannot be merged like for example the
roles and responsibilities of product
owner cannot be given to single
individual who is a scrum master so both
the roles cannot be given a single
individual because it conflicts the
objectives of both the rules so thinking
about putting this one of the team
member becoming scrum Master product
owner thinking in that angle is also
something which is which will not work
which will not give the required results
so now what are these roles what are the
responsibilities where is the focus of
each of the roles so let us discuss on
that now when it comes to product owner
so the product owner is primarily
responsible for maximizing the ROI by
determining the product features
prioritizing it into a list what needs
to be focused on for the next print and
constantly re-prioritizing and refining
it so the key points what we need to see
here is so one is determining the
product features
maximizing the ROI the second one and
then re prioritizing and refining the
product backlog now why is that needs to
be done so maximizing Roi in the sense
obviously product owner should closely
work with the business and have an
Insight towards what is that business
require what is that customer require
how it helps customer to accomplish that
result so that it helps the justifying
that investment what they're doing with
the products features and
functionalities
then speaking about re-prioritizing and
refining it it depends on what features
needs to be delivered in what order so
there is already an order which is
defined So based on the change scenario
you can reorder it and product owner has
that ownership and responsibility so the
entire focus is on ensuring the right
product backlog prioritizing it and also
adding that user stories and effects
into
product backlog
depending on what makes sense to the
business
so the scrum Master the next role helps
teams learn and apply scrum to obtain
business value means scrum Master
closely works with the team so he or she
helps remove impediments what is
impediments
something which stops to move forward
something which doesn't allow to deliver
things the way it is required something
which stops right so that needs to be
eliminated that needs to be understood
what are the impediments so when we say
impediments what are the impediments we
can think of the skills and capabilities
of the team that is one thing maybe the
testing environment may be a process so
if anything comes as a bottleneck or
impediments which stops things to move
smoother forward
so scrum Master should work on it
identify that and support team or guide
team to overcome those so protect them
from interfaces that helps the team to
adopt agile practices so encouraging
team to adopt agile practices and
ensuring they demonstrate it and
provides the required value as it's move
forwards so since scrum Master focuses
one side in terms of making scrum team
to work whereas product owner is looking
at the entire product backlog and
working more closely with the business
so they need to have a good handshake to
ensure things go well but these two
roles cannot be merged because since it
has a two different angles and two
different Dynamics so spending time
accomplishing both the things may become
very challenging and conflicting
and the prioritizing will also be
difficult
then scrum team is a collection of all
the individuals who work together to
deliver the requirements of the
stakeholders so self-organizing team
whatever is mentioning what we were
discussing earlier
so these teams comes together each of
the team members will have various
different capabilities so they
contribute at the individual level and
as a team has a whole complement or
contribute towards ultimate output and
outcome and value what they need to
create and this team should have a clear
understanding about the deliverable what
is being done
so is the deliverable what features and
functionality what they're thinking is
that going to create that value
ultimately what is need to be achieved
the requirements fulfillment which is
which needs to be happened to the
customers so they need to have that
understanding the direction should be
clear to the team
so there are certain artifacts to look
at when it comes to scrum so let us look
at that
so now we speak about the artifacts
which are the components of the scrum
process that can improve transparency
and understanding of the work so there
are three artifacts mainly which we call
it as a product backlog Sprint backlog
then product increment so let us see
what is this one by one so when I say
product backlog so it consists of list
of new features changes to be made to
existing features the bug fixes changes
to the infrastructure and several other
activities that the team needs to
deliver to ensure a particular outcome
so this list show product backlogs
becomes with required features and
functionalities what needs to be
delivered so the prioritization of this
has to happen in what order what needs
to be delivered so the product backlog
is the full list which needs to be
delivered as part of this project and as
the project progresses a lot of new
backlog item would be added to the
product backlog as the Dynamics of the
particular scenarios keeps changing so
keeps adding reprioritizing additional
items to the backlogs are added
depending on what are those Dynamics
so further looking at a Sprint backlog
so Sprint refers to that short period of
iterations
right so which the team aims to get a
given amount of work done so it helps
teams deliver working software in a
frequent manner so Sprint could be
between one to four weeks long depending
on what is the deliverable is so Sprint
backlog is a subset of product backlogs
so that prioritize the item what is
taken into Sprint which is a Time boxed
iterations
the Sprint backlog contains the task the
team aims to complete to satisfy the
Sprint goal so what is that Sprint goal
so each of those iterations the time box
iterations will have a specific
objective to accomplish so the Sprint
goal is the objective decided for the
Sprint as an outcome of negotiation
between the product owner and the team
so what can be delivered how long it
takes to deliver so when it has to be
delivered the target may be given by
product owner but is it possible
feasible to complete it there next there
is some negotiation which happens there
so they decide they agree yes we can do
it we cannot do it if at all we can do
it what is that it takes in terms of
effort time and cost so everything is
decided discussed
so that objective of that particular
iterations is agreed upon so once it is
agreed I think a team should first
identify the tasks from the product
backlog that need to be delivered to
achieve the goal so these stars are then
added to spread backlog so there should
be an agreement between both and once it
is added once it is agreed as part of
that Sprint the deliverable the output
of the Sprint would be the one which
needs to be completed as part of it the
objectives the goal the results which is
specific working software
then product increment so this refers to
the combination of all product backlog
tasks completed in the Sprint and the
value of the increment of previous
prints now when we speak about lean
clean speaks about elimination of waste
it speaks about value streams
now in each of these prints as we have a
working software being delivered now
each of these piece should keep
complementing to the what is the one
which is already delivered and what is
being delivered in future
so keeping that in mind every
deliverable will be implemented or
configured in such a way that there is
no specific bottlenecks there is no
specific constraints which arises so
this needs to be kept in mind which
requires the entire visibility into what
is that ultimate objective we are going
to accomplish so in this product
increment all those combination of the
product backlogs task which is being
done should keep this in mind team
should be very clear about it so I in
the first Sprint I delivered something
in the Sprint 2 I delivered something
but I cannot integrate them they cannot
work together it will lead into the
further issues and then complications
that should not happen
so when we say agile it's about moving
faster fine so responding to change fine
but that should not lead towards further
complexity it should make things simpler
smoother so scrum is stressing on that
part
so an increment refers to
inspectable usable work done at the end
of the Sprint it represents a step
towards overall goal or vision of the
project as I was mentioning then the
outcome should be in usable condition
even if the product owner doesn't decide
to release it so it should be a newsable
condition so two things we speak about
so one is uh release other one is
deployment
now people usually get confused between
release and deployment so release about
this part what we're speaking about
product is usable
so it is released product is usable but
only after deployment user will have an
access to use it
so that is the difference release makes
a product usable whereas deployment
makes it available to the user to use so
this difference people should know so
release doesn't mean that it is already
available for user to use so this
understanding of the difference should
also be there so that one can understand
what it means by release as well and
what it means by deployment that's why
when we speak about divorce we keep
speaking about cacd in cicd we speak
about continuous integration continuous
uh delivery and continuous deployment so
in continuous delivery you're speaking
about release basically so once it is
released it becomes usable so once it is
deployed it is available for user to use
and that's about the scrum artifacts now
let us look at scrum framework how that
scrum framework looks like in entirety
so what are the components comes into
picture already we spoke about the scrum
approach itself what it is
now we spoke about understanding
artifacts then we spoke about roles in
scrum the activities for each of the
roles we understood now where do we see
all of this when we look at a scrum
framework so that picture let us see
so when we say scrum framework already
we spoke about the product backlog we
can see that it is in the left side in
the beginning we have a Sprint planning
so we spoke about Sprint the time box
iterations and from the product backlog
the items which is moving towards Sprint
to a specific Sprint what needs to be
delivered which become Sprint backlog
now the backlog items are taken and
scrum team work on it and does this
daily scrum meeting and once the
deliverables of that particular Sprint
happens then there is a review on it
then the increment is delivered and at
the same time that retrospective what
was planned versus what is delivered
that is checked if you look at from
Sprint review so you have a
retrospective to check what is Plant
versus what is being delivered at the
same time the review points will come
and get updated to product backlog as
well to the product owner so product
owner should be aware what is delivered
what is spending to be delivered and
that increment is further delivered so
this is increments what is delivered to
production what is deployed in the
production should have values that
integration which happens both all the
increments coming together to provide
that fulfillment of the requirement as
well as creating that value what is
required
so product backlog is the first step of
scrum framework is a set of list of
tasks to successfully achieve the goals
of the stakeholders we discuss that
while discussing on product backlog so
further Sprint planning happens where
the team determines the tasks from the
product catalog they will work on and
aim to deliver during the Sprint now
this is negotiated understood agreed and
then moved towards Sprint to get
delivered
then Sprint backlog are the tasks
discussed during the Sprint planning
means the previous step and I'll show
you the script planning and then add it
to the Sprint backlog once it goes to
the Sprint backlog as part of the time
boxed iterations print the deliverables
should happen
now scrum team the scrum team which is
actually self-organizing team as we
mentioned maybe five to ten nine members
of team working on the task in the
Sprint backlog and they will also have a
daily scrums where the team also
discusses for 15 minutes on the events
where the team member synchronizes
activities and plan what they aim to
achieve in next 24 hours what is
accomplished against what is discussed
in previous daily scrum and then if at
all any further discussions need to be
done in the correction of those that can
be taken as a separate meeting not as
part of the daily scrum so generally
daily scrum meeting would be 15 minutes
it should not go more than that it's an
indicative time so quicker updates to
understand what is happening
then the Sprint review happens where
once the Sprint is complete so Sprint
review happens which involves the team
the scrum master and product owner and
stakeholders to understand what is being
agreed upon and what is being delivered
so reviewed is that fulfilled in the
entirety that is discussed and then
during this meeting the team shows what
they accomplished during the Sprint it
allows time to ask questions make
observations
give feedback and provide suggestions
right
then the product owner also presents the
product backlogs top to the stakeholders
to get feedback for upcoming Sprints and
about things related to the backlog now
this one Sprint is complete for the next
print what should be the prioritization
so the product owner has to speak with
the stakeholders so that there is a good
understanding good handshake that what
needs to be delivered and what is the
priority in the given list
then Sprint retrospective happens so
after this print review Sprint
retrospective happens so during this
meeting what went well like past
mistakes potential issues what are the
new ways to handle them which are
required to be done correctly in the
next iterations or next prints needs to
be identified
data from found from here are
Incorporated when planning the new
Sprint so it works like Lessons Learned
what went well what did not go well what
is that we did for those what did not go
well so what is that learning we have in
these iterations so how can we ensure
that in the upcoming iterations the same
mistakes or will not repeat so those can
be
discussed documented and then consider
while moving to the next spring
then the increment is a workable output
which is given to the stakeholders so
this is where the user actually sees the
workable piece working item and then
they give necessary feedback as well on
the particular application fees or
software piece
then there is something called scrum
board which is used during this flow of
scrum right from product backlog to the
creation of that increment so let us
look at what is a scrum board which is
used during the scrum practice so scrum
board is a physical or virtual tool that
helps team to visualize items in the
Sprint backlog so it helps in tracking
what is being delivered what is in
progress and what needs to be delivered
further so it shows all action items
during the daily scrum helping keeping
the team focused on tasks that need to
be completion and the priorities of
those the scrum board is usually present
in a place that's accessible to all team
members it is a visual board right and
can be physical whiteboard and stickers
or virtual software tools which can be
used and displayed on the screen
so the scrum board is divided into
different slots like to do in progress
and done
so when new Sprints are started the
existing board is reset and new scrum
board is created so since it is visual
system I think it is taking the thought
from kanban so visual system always
works effectively because
the moment I know I see something is uh
put egg against my name that I need to
complete this it's got obvious to me
that I will put efforts to complete it
so it's a conscious effort what I will
put it works on my Consciousness so
something which is not visible to me it
is not out of sight is out of mind so I
will not work on it so I may there is a
tendency to forget
first slide here has to do with user
stories and ethics and what I want to do
team is I want to before we get into the
user stories I want to go to the
Whiteboard and I want to just give you a
little bit more information
that might help us in organizing our
discussion that we're about to embark on
here
so a word that is not
in our slides is themes
themes are epics
and user stories grouped together
you know similar ethics and user stories
grouped together for planning purposes
so an epic is Big you would never do an
epic in or pardon me a theme in a Sprint
it's too big
um so it's used for planning purposes
below that I would put epics ethics are
low priority
large user stories
meaning that an ethic will eventually
have to be disaggregated into multiple
user stories
the reason it would be low priority is
because if it if an epic was higher up
on the product backlog
it would have to be more detail that's
when you would break it down so ethics
are usually going to live at the lower
uh priority levels of a product backlog
and as user stories are completed and
the Epic rises in priority it will
eventually be broken down into more
manageable user stories so great big low
priority user stories
then we have user stories themselves
user stories
are functions
or features
that the product owner wants to have
developed a user story turns into
working software
that provides value to the customer and
um and the product owner is the customer
voice the product the owner is the one
who would accept the reject completed
user stories
and then there are tasks
and a reminder when we were talking
about the Sprint planning meeting we
said the Sprint planning meeting is uh
got two parts to it the first part is
selecting all of the user stories that
are going to be included in the Sprint
and then disaggregating each of those
users stories into tasks
that's then in the Sprint planning
meeting and then those tasks are the
things that are actually then done when
the work of the Sprint begins
user stories can be estimated in story
points
or ideal days
most teams favor story points they might
start with ideal days but they will then
usually end up going to story points
um tasks are estimated in I
Ideal Time
which is usually ours okay so now back
to our slides so at the top left a use
case could be an example of a user story
so it's something that
um the user wants to do and how the
system should support it
um like a use case could be
um select and pay for items in a catalog
now that could actually be an epic or
maybe a theme because maybe it would get
disaggregated into log on screen uh
catalog uh shopping cart and checkout
but so the use case could either be a
standalone user story or it could
actually be a number of user stories
that would result from it below that
requirement it could be a functional
requirement a technical task or even a
bug fix
so I'm going to go back to the
Whiteboard and a product backlog
is going to have a lot of user stories
that come from the customer
right whatever the customer wants done
they know that it has to do some
development work in order for the user
stories to even be able to work you know
there's some system level non-functional
requirements that need to be done and so
there could be
Tech user stories
and then
can you see this low
I can't see your chats but then there
could also be
defect user stories there could even be
risk user stories now what could happen
is that
um the product owner range these
in priorities so this one first and that
one then that one and the team says well
the only thing is is that
um we have to do some development work
before we can actually do user story two
and so what we really need to do is
insert that before the uh the second
priority user story
and so the priority of the user stories
in the product backlog while it might
start with just being you know simple
functional user stories coming from the
product owner it will evolve until it
includes some other things that are also
considerations when it comes to
priorities because of you know successor
predecessor relationships dependencies
and things like that are considerations
a user story be uh back to the the
screen
um bottom left now the user story
um can use a fictitious user or a
Persona to help uh the team or the the
team and the product owner to get an
idea of okay who's going to be doing
this function uh what are they going to
need in order to be able to complete the
function Etc so you try and come up with
an actual well a fictitious but a person
who's actually doing it to kind of get
out of the realm of you know listing
requirements and you know specs and
things like that and say okay what's the
user experience need to look like top
right template a portion of a user story
is
um let me back up so a user story card
um is usually going to contain
um a brief description of the user story
using some kind of a meta language
format like we're suggesting right here
as a user or Persona I want this feature
so that I can
so not unlike our
um estimating session here as a frequent
traveler I want to eat grapes so I can
be healthier in the one that we didn't
do uh the inventory system as a customer
okay there's a a user I want to get cash
back so I don't have to wait in line at
the bank okay
here's another user story as a consumer
I want the shopping cart functionality
to easily purchase items online and
maybe that could be customer as well
um as an executive right as a suit
I want to generate a sales report so I
know which departments need to improve
their productivity
as a buyer so you can see I tried to
come up with these different roles right
here executive buyer sales rep Etc
um
and that's the format as a type of user
I want some kind of goal
um or feature and uh so that's some kind
of a reason
the below that connect
the dots by writing all of the user
stories necessary to uncover
the entire use case so like we were
talking about right here if you want to
be able to purchase items online from a
catalog that might be a multiple user
stories in order to support that use
case and so of course we would want to
be able to connect the dots and see
where all the user stories fit in into
the overall goal of the project or
release
and the stories
um
excuse me
are grouped
to form an epic or higher level story so
epic or theme
stories can then be split into child
stories or tasks and so that's what we
were covering before right you see you
have themes
up at the top that's the biggest
grouping if you will used primarily for
um you know high level planning purposes
so you have your themes then you have
your epics which are large user stories
um low priority and they're going to
have to be broken down into smaller user
stories like in the question that we had
at the end of the the last section where
the product owner needed something done
and the team said well based on the size
of this user story it's going to take
three Sprints to do well a user story
has to be small enough to be completed
within a shingle Sprint
so a Sprint can contain more than one
user story but a user story cannot stand
sprints so that feature or function that
was in the question was probably more
like an epic it was something that would
need to be
disaggregated into smaller user stories
or perhaps it was more of a use case
that would need more than one user story
in order to actually deliver the overall
use case
let's see as a product supervisor I want
to see an unfinished part list
at the end of the day so that I can
reallocate work the next day
great user story description
well done barrage
um did you hear that team as a product
supervisor I wanted to see an unfinished
part list at the end of the day so I can
reallocate work the next day that is a
well-crafted description of a user story
I want you to memorize you were hoping I
was done with the memorization part
so I want you to
um
remember that we have to invest in our
user stories
and I was going over to the Whiteboard
and I didn't change cameras so let me do
that
I recommend
um
you know figuring out how you memorize
best
so that you can if
um well not if you wanted to what I
recommend is being able to write out all
of this stuff on plain white scrap paper
in about 14 minutes because that's the
amount of free time you have in the
tutorial when you're at the uh or when
you're taking the test
engine does a little bit different you
maybe won't have a tutorial the only
time you'd have a tutorial is if you
were at a center taking a test exit has
other options like you can do a
paper-based test
where you get a third party you know a
buddy or somebody who will agree to sort
of Proctor the test for you or you can
do it on your laptop all by yourself and
they have software that watches you
while you're taking the test and they
require you to take the laptop and do
like a 360 so that they can verify that
you don't have any cheat sheets up on
the wall or anything like that but the
point is is is you got to have this
memorized whether you're going to dump
it out on the paper or not when I took
the test I actually did the paper-based
option
um and that was because of some kind of
time constraints and it was the quickest
way to get me into the test and so I
didn't write out any of the stuff I'd
memorized but I had it memorized and I
had it memorized well enough that I
could kind of recall it in my mind's eye
Okay so
we're talking about user stories and you
have to invest in your user stories you
know I like memorizing things by
creating these charts that have the
first letter
of the word or phrase that you're
memorizing in a separate column and then
I make up a story you know that
reminds me that I've got to have i n v e
s t this one is pretty easy probably
just invest works
um
but so let's go over that I stands for
independent
independent meaning that each user story
stands on its own
um you don't have
when we're doing scrum you don't do a
user story that won't result in working
software
we just talked about the description of
user stories right so it's a user that
needs some kind of functionality for
some kind of a reason and they're all
independent will they work together of
course they'll work together if that's
the necessity but
um if you developed a log on screen you
could demonstrate working software for
the login screen there might be another
user story that is
um you know has to do with displaying uh
the catalog and being able to flag or
select items that you want to purchase
but there'd be working software for that
would they work together yes but each
user story would complete or result in
some kind of working software and they
have to be independent
negotiable
negotiable in the way the user story is
going to be implemented
the product owner doesn't dictate to the
team the team doesn't say it it's only
this way and we don't want to hear
anything from you so there are
discussions about the size and
implementation for each user's user
story so the product owner can't make it
so detailed
that there's no room for discussion and
the possibility of you know the team
coming up with Solutions other than what
the product owner was attempting to
dictate
um V stands for valuable
meaning each user story has to create
value for the customer or the end user
e it has to be estimable
as an estimatable except estimatable is
not really a word it's estimable
um and answers for small
has to be small enough to be done in a
single Sprint if we're doing two week
Sprints has to be able to be done in two
weeks or less if we're doing four week
Sprints it could be a larger user story
but it would still have to be done in
four weeks or less
and then the last one the t is testable
every user story needs to be testable
and it needs to be testable at two
levels remember our triangle needs to be
testable at the intrinsic quality level
unit tests Etc and also testable at the
extrinsic level which is the customer
point of view which is acceptance so
every user's story uh has to be testable
okay so that's invest and so let's add
that to our list of things to memorize
invest
and then the next one we have here is
um the three C's of a user story
so the first C team is card
so user stories should be able to be
written on a four by six inch index card
or some media similar to that
card
does the check and see is conversation
the user story card is the item that is
used for the team and the product owner
to talk and discuss in order to make
sure that
the product owner and the team are on
the same page when it comes to what is
actually supposed to be developed and
um
uh what you know so what it's supposed
to look like at the end which leads us
to the third one which is confirmation
each user story essentially has to have
acceptance tests
um in it itself
so card 4x6 conversation that's the
starting point that's where uh the team
and the product owner discussed and then
eventually there will be acceptance
tests included on the user story card
um in order to be used during the Sprint
review to
assure that it's acceptable that there's
confirmation
oh oh let's add that to the memorization
list
so
three C's
all right now I've got an example here
of a user story card
so we're looking right here
and if you were to go out on the
internet and search user story cards
they would be similar there would be
some differences of course
um
but typically what you're going to have
is you're going to have a title or a
name for the user story and then there's
going to be some kind of unique
identifier like user story 321 then
there will be the description like we
just talked about
as a librarian I want to have the
facility of searching a book by
different criteria so that I will save
time while serving a customer
then there might be some other
descriptive words or links to other
information that might be necessary and
then there would be acceptance criteria
or tests sometimes these get included on
the back of the card but the point is is
that they are on the cord on the card
rather
then there will be an estimate of size
it could be ideal days or story points
as I mentioned most teams do story
points that's more likely what you'll be
tested on as opposed to
Ideal days but you know we'll cover both
so you understand
but the difference is
there is probably it's not listed here
but there's probably going to be a
value point assignment this is where the
product owner
um kind of determines in a relative way
the value of the stories just like we
were doing in planning poker the product
owner might say well this story is twice
as valuable as a as uh this other one
comparing them together and this is what
um these value points are what's used to
prioritize the user stories that's
supposed to be a v as in value points
and then typically there's also going to
be a indication sometimes it's just by
colors it could be words that has to do
with you know where the story came from
did it come from the customer that would
be considered a functional requirement
if it came from the team that would be
from the technical domain I'm trying to
write where from
uh you know it's not me team it's the
mouse
clearly
it's hard to uh do that that's from
where from
um here it's got uh customer tech you
could also have defect you could maybe
have risk
um and then there's also going to be an
X Factor
um which would be
some kind of word probably like
um
stable
um erratic
um incomplete
something like that to uh so that the
team is designating the user story in uh
respect to the amount of uncertainty or
risk that's associated with that user
story and because all of that's a part
of the story right the story is going to
be turned into working software there
may need to be some efforts to actually
figure out how to actually do that user
story
so that's the The X Factor over to the
right here on the same chart we have
some comments about
if you are using a software package
excuse me like Trello or jira or
something like that excuse me the user
story cards will generally be able to
contain more information using you know
dynamic links and things like that could
even include things like responsible
team member or depending on how you're
doing it you would break the user Story
down into tasks and you might have team
members assigned to various tasks for
the user story
um okay so that's typically what a user
story card is like sometimes they're
cards sometimes they're like on sticky
notes and they're put up on a kanban
board if you're using kanban to track
the project
if you have a story that is too large to
be completed in a Sprint it's going to
have to be subdivided or we call it
disaggregation into
smaller user stories and there's uh
three ways that we're proposing here
that you could go about doing that you
could split it based on operational
boundaries for example as an operator
one needs to manage reservations which
could be split for example there could
be one portion that is that has to do
with making a reservation another one
that has to do with modifying it and yet
another one that has to do with
canceling it so
um that could be split into in this
construct here three separate user
stories you could also separate based on
exceptions or cross-cutting concerns for
example in the beginning develop only
one main path like accept repayment for
a loan
then address exceptions like what if a
person over pays then come up with a
user story that recognizes that and
processes a refund and or gives the
option of allocating the overpayment to
a future payment or something like that
and then also
um
that's on other concerns like the check
access restrictions or record name of
operator so maybe
um you know when you're working on
accepting payments or processing refunds
it's going to check on who the operator
is or track that so that if at a later
time you know who is it that gave this
refund here well you could look and see
you know okay the the operator's name
was recorded or maybe you put some
restrictions so that maybe not everybody
is allowed to do a refund and so you
would have levels of users that have
different privileges
okay and then down at the bottom split
Based on data boundary series for an
example you know as an accountant one
needs to enter balance sheet information
which could then be split into summary
information
and separately
receivable details or you know maybe you
could have AP you know so you could have
different portions of the overall
um
balance sheet activities that need to be
done
so enter AR enter AP
etera
make sense so just to kind of prompt you
give you some ideas about what to do in
a scrum project if you have the scenario
arise where a user story is being
estimated by the team and it won't fit
into a Sprint
it's too big
now when it comes to determining value
for user stories this is primarily owned
by the product owner right and it always
comes back to money but money you know
the value can be looked at from
different points of view
so new Revenue obviously you know
getting new customers and having them
buy stuff
well below that there's another
consideration incremental Revenue uh so
somebody's in the process of placing an
order
um maybe there are some premium features
that could be add-ons at that point in
time
or maybe added later on so you have an
existing customer who actually buys
um more of or enhanced parts of the
existing thing they already purchased or
are in the process of purchasing
retained value so this is
um
you know
retaining customers so that they don't
go to a competitor
and then the bottom one is operational
efficiency you know how could things be
done to speed up the process of whatever
it is so that the cost of delivering the
product is reduced
so this then leads us to a discussion
about priorities recognizing that there
are some priority concerns that come
from both the customer domain as well as
the technical domain
and there are some prioritization models
um if we look right here there is
value-based prioritization and the
hierarchy of that would be high value
followed by high risk followed by high
value
and then low risk followed by low value
and then low risk
so you know we might have written this a
little bit differently but that's
value-based prioritization and this is
primarily the product owner with maybe
some input from the team just simply
deciding what he or she wants then most
listening to the team say well you know
there's some you know greater risks with
this user story than that and so you'd
probably want to persuade the product
owner to take care of high-risk stuff
first because that would have an
yeah
a uh oh excuse me sorry an impact on the
future things that need to be done
there's the the Cano model
which looks at each of the user stories
and classifies them as being mandatory
linear or exciters
and the mandatory items are those user
stories that are musts and they'll never
move Beyond move the customer or the end
user Beyond neutral it's if they're not
there it creates dissatisfaction if the
the you the product owner and the team
has done a good job in identifying what
are the mandatory or threshold items
um you would see that
um
um it just gets it to neutral that's
what's expected for the product
linear items user stories are those user
stories that as they are implemented
progressively throughout the project and
added to the feature set it will linear
increase customer satisfaction and it
can be you know in their absence
dissatisfaction all the way up to high
implementation creating a great deal of
satisfaction for the customer and then
the third category is exciters and
delighters
and those are features or functions
those are user stories that are not
mandatory and the absence of them will
never result in satisfaction going below
neutral but by adding them
um you could create excitement and
Delight for the customer
these would typically be things that are
features that would be included in a
premium version of the product or maybe
add-ons that are promoted you know at
the point of sale you know if you
thought about this because it'll really
help you or whatever
that's the channel model and then
there's uyghur's relative weighting
method
and
um this is all using numbers so each
feature is given a value for its benefit
and its penalty given a value for
penalty meaning what's the pain if that
feature or function is not included
and then there is
um
um the cost side and the risk side
and then those are all calculated
together and that results in
excuse me a ranking or a hierarchy which
gives you the priority for the user
stories
um we also talked about Moscow didn't we
did we talk about Moscow uh Moscow is
another prioritization model must could
I said that differently must should
could won't Moscow mscw must should
could won't
and we talked about that one thank you
for that confirmation
does it seem like a long time ago or is
it just me I know it was just last
weekend but it's like last year
okay so now let's talk about velocity
um uh Priyanka that is exactly right
um
so velocity is the capacity of the team
to complete
work in a single iteration
so the team has estimated the user
stories uh for size or ideal days and
um the Sprints are going to be three
weeks in duration obviously not all user
stories can be completed in a shingle
Sprint and be done with the project well
I guess maybe I shouldn't say Obviously
what I'm saying that I'm thinking well
maybe you had a very small short
duration project so you could but the
point is is that it's the team's
capacity to complete work in a given
Sprint and it is
an observation it's not a prediction so
if we're working on Sprint 5
and we're working on determining what
our velocity is
then it would be the average of the
previous four sprints
if there were any uh outliers you'd you
would disregard those
um
and so it's an observation
if we look over to question or uh box
number two here velocity is used to deal
with
determining how many user stories we are
going to include in a given Sprint and
also how many Sprints are we going to
need to create a release or a set of
user stories
and here's an example
in box number three a team completed
five user stories that were sized five
three eight thirteen and two
two user stories each sized five were
left half complete
what is the velocity of the team
and the answer is either going to be
31 or 36.
31 is the sum of the completed user
stories if you were 36 you were claiming
half of the two that were five so that
would be a total of 10 so you claim half
of it would be 5 would take you to 36.
but it's not going to be 36 because the
only thing that counts towards
progress is working software so even if
the team had finished nine out of 10
story points for a user story meaning
it's almost done and then the Sprint
ends that doesn't get counted towards
velocity
and you don't mess around with velocity
you can mess around with your estimating
and you can mess around with
um you know what user stories are going
to be completed in a Sprint but you
don't the the velocity is not variable
it is what it is based on past
performance
when it comes to levels of planning
we have What's called the planning onion
and let me walk you through this here up
at the the brightest area is the vision
level so the vision level that's the
suits right they're the ones that have
the strategy and objectives for the
company and where it's going and so they
have that overall big vision for the uh
company
which is likely going to include
products and each product should have a
road map
my example of that website that I'm
working on has three versions which make
up the product roadmap version one is
the free site version two is the
membership site and version three is the
um uh the pay referral commissions uh uh
version of the site
and
roadmap
road map ported by releases
so for my project I have three releases
so all of the user stories needed for
the free version are in release one all
of the additional user stories that are
needed for the
um
uh paid version the subscriber version
uh and then also for version three those
are all releases three releases
and then for each Sprint we will be
pulling user stories from the release
that we're working on a release is
likely going to take multiple Sprints
and
um and then the Sprints are populated by
the individual user stories which are
then disaggregated into tasks
and we do the
excuse me the daily scrum
which is the daily level of planning and
coordination so we call that the
planning onion
we already kind of talked about the
release and road map
um concept here so let's just review
this quickly
um Preparatory is high level ethics and
determine goals and releases so we'll
use epics and themes in order to group
things together you know what should be
included and what's released so what are
the goals for the releases then the
first bullet point established goals of
release based on market demand
regulatory needs or customer
expectations
for each release you want to estimate
the target stories
repeat until the target stories are
assigned and iteration length
I should that should it's blending some
things here
um be able to estimate velocity and then
assign stories to the Sprints so we keep
estimating the user stories and we keep
organizing uh that until we can do that
we can come up with an iteration length
or Sprint length and then figure out
what our velocity for each Sprint is and
then assign stories to the uh the
Sprints uh the the next bullet down
iterate until the user stories and
release date meets conditions of
satisfaction
so that's a definition of then or
acceptance for the release and try not
to pack too much into a release backlog
so
uh
uh too many user stories into a Sprint
you want to have the timelines
appropriate and what are included in the
events makes sense
okay so here's a bit more about release
planning on this slide here
um you've got the product backlog here
on the left and then we might come up
with a release plan which could be
flipped and could be looked at uh
horizontally and you probably plan
um about
three releases in advance
um or at least you're doing more of the
detailed planning on that because things
are going to emerge when we do you know
Sprint one that's going to help in
Sprint two and things that happen in
Sprints one and two that are going to
help
release three and then you've got you
know your subsequent releases where
we're just doing very high level
planning it's called rolling wave
planning where we do detailed planning
for things in the future and tandem with
doing high level planning for things in
uh the future
did I say that right detail planning for
things in the near term intend them with
high level planning for things in the
future
um and we talked about deciding as late
as possible I believe meaning that it's
better to actually plan the latest
releases
mm-hmm uh for purposes of
making sure we have more information the
most information available
okay so estimation
let's start at the top left the
principles behind estimation understand
the cone of uncertainty which is an
estimate or best guess to begin with and
then progressively becomes more accurate
in fact let's just take a break and look
at the cone of uncertainty
so at the very beginning of a project
there's going to be a high level of
uncertainty
if I were to draw this chart I would
make it a little bit more like
this
so clearly you're going to de-risk the
project
as early as you can and then eventually
all risk disappears when the project is
done risk is uncertainty
okay below that the only estimate that
matters is the one given by the chain
supported by this uh comment here
nothing is impossible for the one who
doesn't have to do it so the product
owner is like Keem come on you can do
this the team's like no we know what our
velocity is no the product owner says
I'm telling you there's no way that that
can't be done I know you can do it I
trust you I believe in you
but the product owner doesn't ask you to
have to do the work okay copyright
overestimation and underestimation is
always going to be an issue that we deal
with
it's more likely that we will
underestimate than overestimates
and by looking at our velocity from
iteration or Sprint to Sprint
um there could be some information that
is
um showing us that we're underestimating
for example meaning we're thinking we
you know the user stories are smaller
than they are and that we can get you
know a certain number done in the Sprint
and then there's a fail well that would
mean then that would be discussed during
the retrospective and then we would do
something different going forward which
might include doing some re-estimating
scrum estimating is not necessarily more
difficult however scrum exposes bad
estimates sooner which is a good thing
when we were doing our
um
uh planning poker you could see that
um the first time as a team you know we
didn't know each other we didn't know
everybody's thoughts and concerns and
those kinds of things you know get
shared and absorbed as a project goes on
and so there's a higher awareness of
that
so
um what we would say is that
um using estimation techniques from
estimation techniques might be more
inaccurate at the beginning of a project
but they will quickly become very
accurate as the project advances forward
so is there a question here can velocity
be increased over a period of time for
the project yes it can now it's not that
it can't it will increase if the team is
learning how to work together better and
better you would expect that if I can
just use my mouse here if we were
tracking
velocity so this would be points
completed over here let me just do pts
for points and down here is time
and we go from Sprint to Sprint right
you would expect that maybe you know the
first couple of Sprints the team would
be learning how to work together and
there would be a steep curve and then it
would kind of flatten out and maybe have
you know a slow rise going forward as
the team emerges as a high performing
team they get better at their cross
functional Behavior you know somebody's
shake the team just keeps chugging on
other things you know just
um oh sorry
I bumped the thing on my screen there
um
um so the team you know learns how to
work better together and you know their
estimates become more accurate Etc and
you would expect a high for a high
performing team to have a uh a result
like this for velocity where there's
quick Improvement and then it kind of
stabilizes and then begins to tick
upwards
okay we talked about the cone of
uncertainty let's talk about ideal time
um when we do estimating for user
stories
um we do it in ideal days when we do
estimating for tasks we do it in ideal
time which means hours I think that's on
the Whiteboard or it was on the
Whiteboard oh it was on it
um so ideal time is the amount of time
it takes to complete a piece of work
but that's based on
the notion that
the team member or members are available
to do just the work
with no distractions or anything at all
so assuming that
um priyanta could sit down add a
keyboard and code for eight hours
without taking a break for lunch no
phone calls no discussions no meetings
of any kind just work eight hours how
much could be done in that eight hours
by Priyanka that's what ideal time is
but the thing of it is is that there is
no such thing as somebody being able to
spend every minute of every day only
doing work there will be distractions
so it has to be converted into elapsed
time now we don't convert it to elapsed
time at the user story level but we do
convert it to elapsed time when we are
dealing at the task level
and what that looks like is
you know for each team member you're
going to have to do it separately
because some team members have more
distractions than others some might have
other duties that pull them away
um whatever the case may be you
determine how much time in a given day a
team member is available to do work so
say it's five hours out of eight for one
maybe it's six hours out of eight for
another maybe it's four out of eight but
you figure out what it is and then you
take the average and that average
availability is used then to convert
Ideal Time into elapsed time
yeah
um I should have circled this box here
because we talked about this as well
um and then I already mentioned this
year only considers actual work time not
the distractions so that's the concept
of Ideal Time
when it comes to story points it's
different than that
they are a measure of size relative to
each other so we were doing planning
poker this morning where we were looking
at grapes versus apples and then we were
looking at oranges and and what else do
we have watermelons and coconuts and we
weren't trying to figure out how much
time it would take to eat grapes as
opposed to how much time it would uh
take to eat a coconut it's clear that
it's going to take longer to eat a
coconut because there's more effort
involved so we have a sense that it's
going to take more time but comparing
the coconut to our Baseline of two right
we came up with a baseline of two for
the smallest user story We compare
eating coconuts to that Baseline and we
say okay you know what it's going to
take more effort to eat the coconut than
it is to eat grapes or apples
yeah
so you so you got like we did you can
also triangulate for example when we did
our planning project this morning or
this morning for me rather at the
beginning
um oh that's not it that is the daily
stand-up
here it is
if I had said Team I want you to pick a
small user story a medium user story and
a large user story
um and then we would then compare other
stories to those three and so we would
kind of triangulate on it let's say that
we did uh you know two was small
uh I'm sorry I'm saying that wrong
grapes was small apples were medium and
coconuts were large
well if we then looked at Orange and we
said well you know orange is
um smaller than Apples but bigger than
grapes so we would know this would fit
in between grapes and apples
um
and so let's say you know we had apples
at five and grapes at two then we would
say an orange is probably going to be
three
and the values you know now I used in
our example the modified Fibonacci
series
what we do in scrum and agile if we're
using story points we're going to use a
non-linear scale for the values so down
at the bottom
here there's the modified Fibonacci
Sequence the way the Fibonacci sequence
works by the way
um
um it's the
the value is the sum of the two on the
right so let me break this right here
because this is a modified Fibonacci so
13 is five plus eight eight is three
plus five five is two plus three and
three is one plus two
if we were doing the real Fibonacci
series this wouldn't be 20 it would be
13 plus 8 which would be 21.
um I I don't know why some use modified
Fibonacci and others not but that's just
kind of a common thing to do if you're
doing planning poker you give everybody
seven cards one two three five eight
thirteen and twenty
um another non-linear scale is doubling
one two four eight sixteen you typically
don't go too far to the left with the
values because that either means that
you're being too granular or you've got
stories that are probably too big and
they need to be just aggregated
now somebody just chatted here
um should some buffer time be included
in the actual estimates
um
let me answer that question first by
going back to Ideal time and then I'm
going to come back to story points and
answer the question
when we're estimating in ideal time we
don't add a special amount of time that
we would call a buffer we just allow for
the distractions and the interruptions
which could look like a buffer right
you're saying you know
um you know priante if based on your
duties in the organization and our work
day of eight hours you're typically
available to be doing your project work
five out of those eight hours
so when we are converting ideal time to
elapsed time
um you know we will be building in extra
time based on distractions and
interruptions we would not call it a
buffer but that's essentially what we're
doing now when it comes to user stories
that we're using story points it is
different
the points are for the entire amount of
the work and why might we need to have
some extra time for a user story well
it's likely going to be driven by
uncertainty there might be other uh
things that impact it but that's the
main thing
sorry team
so when the team is estimating the size
of the user story they will be including
in their discussion and estimates any
extra time or buffer time that would be
needed for uh that user story to be
completed
so do we accommodate
um uncertainty when we're using story
points yes we're looking at the The X
Factor and if we've got an unstable user
story then we're probably going to say
you know this is going to be a bigger
user story than one that's similar but
has a much lesser level of uncertainty
um so that's the story points let's
compare the two
um Ideal Time uses things like hours and
days which is easier to explain outside
the team
right the suits like things in days and
hours everybody's estimate may be
different not a bad thing it's easier to
do at the beginning because we're
oriented to think about time and it does
kind of shine a light on wasted time
waypoints
are harder to explain outside the team
um you know the suit says well how long
is it going to take to do user story 301
and our answer is
um well that's a 10 user story Point
user story and the suit's saying what
does that mean tell me how long it's
going to take so the suits have to be
converted to uh uh story points now
here's the thing it's a lot easier to
get consensus when we're estimating in
story points and once we get good at it
it's going to be much faster
we have to remember it's not comparable
across teams so you know a team working
together will have its own tennis system
for sizing the stories and another team
that might even be working on the same
project will have a CO a whole different
uh scheme and so if the velocity of one
team is 25 in the velocity of another is
50 it doesn't mean that the team with
the velocity of 50 is able to do more
work than the teams whose velocity is
25.
we did when we got our day going we
started with
a planning poker exercise and so you
know we used all of the team members so
we selected the team the product owner
was there to answer any questions
the team discussed each of the story
cards and then decided what their vote
was going to be and then everybody voted
it once if there were outliers they were
discussed and the reasons for that those
variances those outliers were then part
of the discussion and then we did
another round of voting and we would
keep doing that until we had our
estimates converge or we reached
consensus on them
okay so advantages of planning poker
it's fun it's quick it gets the whole
team involved the the team understands
um a little bit about all of the stories
everybody contributes his or her
expertise and the discussion during the
estimation provides Clarity in the
direction approach and even a bit of
design if we were in the same room team
and we were doing a planning poker
activity like we did at the beginning of
our day uh together
we would be able to you know model it a
little bit better or if we tried to
unmute everybody but you could hear the
background noise I've tried doing it it
doesn't really work but you get the idea
that if the team's discussing and things
like that you would actually get to the
point where your estimates would
converge and the team would say okay
this user story size is you know
whatever it is
okay so we need to wrap things up for
the day so we are ending right here and
that means tomorrow when we get together
we're going to be doing slide 20 you're
starting with that which is Affinity
estimating
and let's see Affinity estimating we go
through that we're going to talk about
tracking progress using
um
information radiators and then we're
going to talk about what we do when we
find variances between the plan and the
actual results and then we'll have our
quiz now let's talk
the values of scrum now this is
different than pillars this is
values so there are five
um values for that and
this is something that I want you to
memorize so I'm going to switch my
cameras here and go to the white port
and we're going to add
to our list
Oh wrong color
you can tell I'm a project manager
because that would bother me
so the five
values of scrum
and there's an acronym you can see that
on the screen right she Force
okay so five
values of scrum
and she f o r c
and you kind of know my style here you
don't have to do it this way you know
whatever works for you but have some
kind of a strategy for memorizing things
it will probably serve you well
so the um the first C is commit
commitment
the next one there are four four F is
focus
is openness
that two ends are one I don't know
openness
we'll blame it on the marker if it's not
right R is for respect
and the last C is
courage
and so there's your little chart right
there and
um
let me just briefly go over these
that is will be a big surprise here
we've talked about some of them already
in one context or another
um so the for commitment that means the
commit the team is going to commit to
deliver value to the customer
um they're on board there's the buy-in
all of that's there Focus the team is
going to focus on the few important
things
um
at a time so we're going to do time
boxing uh we're not going to do things
broadly specifically uh focus on a few
things at a time oh is openness that's
analogous to the T transparency and the
pillars meaning we're going to be
completely open in Sharing
um information about the project our own
opinions our fears our concerns Etc R
stands for respect and that's kind of a
360 view we respect ourselves we respect
others we respect the uh Concepts that
we are using as part of scrum and
um
um and you know and we respect the
others other stakeholders as well 360.
and the last C stands for courage and
that's the courage to make commitments
uh even when we're in an uncertain
environment
um
courage to deal with fear that comes
from a failure uh courage to share
disagreements openly yet respectfully
courage to participate in debating
technical approaches
Etc
so now let's go to the scrum life cycle
chart and what I want to do is I want to
elaborate on this just a little bit
and I'm going to try and use my mouse to
do some some additions to this
um
first of all we have the product backlog
the product backlog has to be kept
current and we call that grooming
grooming is adding user stories and
removing user stories from the product
backlog product backlog is the scope of
the project the product owner owns that
the team assists in that effort related
to grooming is pruning pruning the
backlog is prioritizing and
reprioritizing so the product backlog is
pruned and groomed regularly throughout
the course of the project
now
there is a meeting that takes place
right here which is called the Sprint
planning meeting can I just do PSP here
Sprint planning meeting
okay that is one of the ceremonies or
events that
um
takes place in scrum in the um the
Sprint planning meeting
it is a Time boxed event and it is time
boxed to two hours for each week of the
Sprint so in our example here we have a
30-day Sprint so if we have a four week
Sprint then our Sprint planning meeting
will be eight hours in duration
and two things happen during the Sprint
planning meeting the user stories that
are going to be included in the Sprint
are selected right they're put into the
Sprint backlog which is a subset of the
product backlog containing the user
stories that are going to be completed
during the Sprint
and the second thing that happens during
the Sprint planning meeting is the
selected user stories are then
disaggregated into tasks and estimated
once that's done then the work of the
Sprint begins there will be a daily
scrum like we did at the beginning of
our work day together as our team and
then at the end of the work of the uh
Sprint there will be the Sprint review
Sprint review meeting or ceremony
is also time boxed and it is time boxed
to one hour
for each week of the Sprint so if we're
doing a four week Sprint the Sprint
review meeting would be four hours in
length the primary purpose of the review
is to Showcase and demo the software and
get feedback from relevant stakeholders
and allow the product owner to say I
accept or I reject the work that has
been done
then after that is the Sprint
retrospective
now this is where the team
asks and answers three questions what
went well what did not go well and what
are we going to do different going
forward
regarding the previous Sprint that was
just completed and the ones that is is
just coming up
and then the uh the Sprint itself will
result in working software or value for
the customer and then of course
everything goes back and repeats for as
many Sprints uh as necessary to complete
the scope of the project
um let's see I see a chat here how
similar or different is the product
backlog to SRS software requirement
specs document which is widely used in
projects
um it's different and if you will hang
on to that question we're going to have
a discussion later on about user stories
and that will help you understand uh the
differences
and we'll get into the user stories that
come from the customer and user stories
that come from the tech domain and that
will help answer your question so you
can hang on to that
okay great thanks
okay so a little bit more detailed view
of the scrum Project Life Cycle now
let's talk about a couple other things
here when it comes to
um a Sprint there are some things that
affect the duration of the Sprint
so the team is going to have to decide
how long each of the Sprints are going
to be and things that are a factor
include the stability of the product
backlog If the product backlog is
changing a great deal
um then that's going to argue for
shorter durations
because there's a high level of
uncertainty and so you have a greater
amount of control on your project if you
have shorter Sprints now on the other
hand another factor is the cost of
iterating
every time we do a Sprint there are
costs associated with the Sprint
planning meeting the Sprint review
the Sprint retrospective right people
show up to those meetings you got to pay
them and
um excuse me so there there is an
overhead cost to actually doing sprints
the goal of the Sprint is working
software at the end the end product
should be near releasable or potentially
shippable now there might be working
software that the product owner isn't
going to want to release
um maybe because it as a standalone
component of working software for the
system doesn't create any value or any
usability for end users and maybe you
wait till the end of a release before
you release everything but the idea is
is this working software and it could be
released if the customer wanted to do
that
um
sorry I just dropped something
I see a question there I will Circle
back to your question in just a sec
um the Sprint duration and deliverables
do not change once the team has
committed this is another one of those
things that has to be viewed as absolute
when we're doing scrum so if we say that
we're going to do a two-week Sprint and
we select five user stories based on our
velocity or capacity once that decision
has been made the duration of the Sprint
does not change and we do not add or
remove any user stories
now it could be possible for the product
owner to cancel a Sprint but that would
be extreme that would be because there
is such a major change to the product
backlog that the work of the current
Sprint is going to be completely
irrelevant you don't change the Sprint
you cancel the Sprint and then the
bottom one here the Sprint begins with
planning and ends with review and a
retrospective and there was a question
here are there any issues with combining
the retrospective and the planning
ceremonies and the answer to that is yes
now could they be combined depending on
the environment the answer is yes and
the way we would arrive at whether or
not it would make sense is who's going
to be participating
um but they would be separate
agendas so the agenda for the
retrospective is what went well what did
not go well what are we going to do
different and the mandatory participants
for that meeting are the the team the
scrum team is the scrum Master going to
be there likely as a facilitator is the
product owner going to be there maybe
maybe not if the product owner is there
you know the product owner could maybe
answer questions and help clarify but
the product owner does not weigh in on
what went well but did not go well and
what are we going to do differently that
is all owned by the king in the planning
meeting the product owner has to be
there and the product owner is the main
driver of that meeting the product owner
is talking about or dealing with the
priority the user Stories the teams
weighing in maybe there's some
dependencies that need to be considered
but the product owner has to make the
hard decisions with regards to what's
going to be done in the next Sprint
based on the constraints from the team
like velocity and technology and
sequencing and things like that
so
um I kind of answered that from a real
world point of view yes it could be it's
not desirable on the test they are
completely separate
can I get you there
I'll keep my eye on the chat box make
sure I got that answered well enough for
you and let's move ahead
okay the Sprint planning meeting this is
looking right down here this is
conducted at the beginning of a new
Sprint it's attended by the team the
product owner and the scrum master and
there are two approaches to deciding
what's going to be included in the
Sprint it can be based on commitment and
it can also be based on velocity
and the goal here is to get team buy-in
make sure that there is Clarity between
the team and the product owner as to
what the definition of done looks like
for the user stories that are going to
be included in the Sprint
um of course it should be realistic and
achievable
an issue where you've got you know a
well-meaning product owner that's
driving really hard and the team says
you know we can do these Sprints and the
product owner is saying no come on you
got to do at least one more I gotta have
this one in this Sprint
um you could get a question like that
and it might be what would the scrum
Master do if you had a dominant product
owner that's trying to persuade the team
to do more than the team thinks it can
do
um and that's where the scrum Master
comes in the scrum Master plays the role
of the mentor the coach and uh you know
assisting in the resolution of those
kinds of issues without deciding the
scrum Master is not a decider the team
decides uh when it comes to how and the
product owner decides when it comes to
what
okay the scrum meeting uh daily scrum
we've talked about it right the entire
team attends the meeting could the
product owner be there yes does the
product owner need to be there no
sometimes the product owner can be uh
you know an impediment to the meeting
but would be welcome but if the product
owner started asking questions or became
the focus of questions being asked the
scrum Master would have to help
facilitate a change because that would
not be effective for the daily scrum
duration 15 minutes we talked about that
and the agenda what did I do yesterday
what am I going to do today and what are
my impediments
the Sprint review
now who attends is going to be the team
the product owner the scrum master and
potentially others so
optionally others you know that we would
want to get feedback from would be end
users operations folks Pursuits all of
those would be welcome depending on the
relevance of the software that's being
demoed and being
subject to the acceptance testing and
the product owner you know giving the
thumbs up or the thumbs down when it
comes to acceptance the duration for
this we mentioned this before it's not
just a flat two hours it's one hour per
week
so if you did a four week Sprint you
would plan on the review being a maximum
of four hours in duration the agenda is
to demo the completed software get
feedback and then see where we are when
it comes to the the release plan
attended by the team and I would modify
this slightly and I would say this is
the the mandatory group that needs to be
there optionally the scrum Master would
be there potentially you could have an
external facilitator the role of the
scrum Master would be the facilitator
now
um a good scrub Master being a
facilitator in a retrospective would
have some knowledge of control charts
the five y's
um
um Ishikawa diagrams things like that
and although the scrum Master would not
be participating in the actual use of
the tools the scrum Master would be
facilitating the effective use of those
tools
when it comes to duration the rule is 45
minutes
for each week
oh that was a good four that was kind of
a lousy five
so if you had a two-week
um
uh Sprint then you would have an hour
and a half retrospective Max
and what's the purpose there's the
agenda for the retrospective three
questions what worked well would the not
go well what are we going to do
different and it's not just a chat
session well that would be part of it
you will use tools and techniques like
some that I mentioned control charts
um
Ishikawa diagrams
five y's there's a number of things that
you might use
in order to surface uh assignable causes
for issues so that we could then come up
with a resolution to those
um this is where continuous Improvement
is going to happen you know continuous
improvements the result of other things
but this is the main thing and if you
read a question about the relevance or
the necessity of retrospectives there is
no equivocation you do a retrospective
after every Sprint
if you don't do a retro
um if you don't then there's no
improvement
um you know things just stay static
okay so we talked about the four main
ceremonies right in a scrum project
Sprint planning
you with me
daily stand-up
the Sprint review
and then the Sprint retrospective
it's all considered mandatory for
effectively doing scrum and not doing
them or one of them would be considered
a fail
okay artifacts that we use when it comes
to scrum uh we've talked about the
product backlog we talked about the
Sprint backlog there's also a release
backlog depending on the size of the
project it might be advisable to group
user stories into releases if you have a
product roadmap your releases would line
up for that for example I've got a
a real life project that I'm working on
and my product roadmap is
got three versions it's a website the
first version is free the second version
includes a membership component and the
third uh version includes a referral
commission portion to it and so I will
then
do three releases I'll have all the user
stories that were resolved to in version
one all the the user stories that really
result in version two so that's what the
release backlog is and so if you look at
it and sequence the product backlog is
the overall scope of the project the
release backlog is a subset of the
product backlog and then the Sprint
backlog would be a subset of the release
backlog
the product backlog might look something
like this
um it's a list of user stories that are
written by the product owner and are
going to be developed by the team
members and and didn't we have we had a
product backlog for
the thing that we did this morning right
so here's another example of a product
backlog
this is more of a list
it just has the title there would be a
user story card for each of the items in
the product backlog
um but the idea would be it would be
prioritized uh there could be user
stories that are added or removed
depending on what the product owner
wants product owner owns the product
backlog
um that's a given uh does the product
owner create all the user stories for
the product backlog in isolation no
absolutely not because there are
technical considerations that the
product back or the product owner might
not even consider the product owner's
perspective is more the customer side
the end user side
and so the product owner might not even
think of things like security or
architecture related things and there
might even be user stories that come
from the technical domain that need to
be
developed before some of the products
owners user stories
another artifact is the definition of
done
and this is what forms the agreement
between the product owner and the team
as to when we consider something
completely done
and if we look down here it's
um
where's my I'm looking for my cursor it
says here it's usually prepared by the
scrum master in consultation with the
team
um
that is I would modify this slightly on
the definition of done is really driven
by the team the see the scrum Master is
never a decision maker if you have a
scum Master that's saying we have to
have this in the definition of done then
that's an infringement on the
empowerment of the team I I agree that
this the scrum Master is a part of the
effort to develop the definition of done
um but I would kind of flip that
describe Masters the facilitator it's
the team that still owns that
absolutely because the product owner is
involved in defining the story and what
a fully implemented story looks like so
a list
a short list of what a definition of
done could look like
the story has been fully implemented or
the code completed as described
automated unit tests have been developed
with at least 80 percent code coverage
um it could be more than that
um this is just an example automated
unit tests and acceptance test of the
story are passing no severity has one or
two defects
and then high priority test cases have
been automated and added to the
regression Suite
um the definition of done we point out
is likely to evolve as the team's
maturity increases as the project
advances
there are three distinct roles in scrum
the scrum Master the product owner and
the development team the scrum Master
assists both the development team and
the product owner the scrum Master works
with the product owner to maximize
return on investment
the scrum Master empowers the
development team by fostering creativity
removing impediments and coaching and
mentoring as appropriate
the product owner is responsible for
project success by defining the project
Vision requirements and priorities
the product owner has to resist the
temptation to manage the team or add
more important work after a Sprint has
begun
the product owner has to be willing to
make the hard choices during Sprint
planning
the development team is comprised of
five to nine members with a mix of roles
and has the autonomy to self-organize
and choose how best to meet the goals of
the product owner and is responsible for
the same
a scrum Master is a skilled servant
leader a scrum master has very little
formal Authority however he or she is
expected to assist the team achieve the
intended outcomes without interfering
with the team's autonomy
the scrum Master facilitates the scrum
ceremony such as Sprint planning daily
stand-up Sprint review and Sprint
retrospective
the scrum Master removes obstacles or
impediments faced by the team
the scrum Master is also a process coach
and mentor
the scrum Master must not be a line
manager of the team the scrum Master is
not to be a Taskmaster either
the scrum Master is not a technical or
design Authority nor is he or she a
decision maker for the team
throughout the course of the project the
scrum Master must not do anything to rob
the team of its empowerment and ability
to self-organize
let's talk about the attributes of a
scrum Master scrum Masters need to
exhibit responsibility even though they
are not solely accountable for the
team's output
they will consider it their
responsibility to remove anything that
impacts the team's productivity
they will try to enable the team to do
the best that it can
they are humble
they will work in the background and let
the team take all the glory
they will use we statements and seldom
use any I statements
they are able to set aside their ego and
shower all their attention on the team
they are by Nature collaborative they
will encourage the team to have
conversations among each other and with
other stakeholders outside the team they
will nudge all the right people into
getting involved and work together and
trying to solve problems they are
committed to the team cause
even if being a scrum Master is a
part-time task for them they will give
the highest priority to the team's needs
hence the scrum Master's work allocation
especially if they are part-time needs
to take this into consideration
they are able to influence
they are naturally good communicators
and able to convince others to adopt
different approaches they apply various
techniques to mobilize organizational
resources when required
walk the political tightrope when
required and in general do whatever it
takes to get the team the assistance it
needs
they are knowledgeable
it is clear that as process coaches for
the team scrum Masters need to be
experts in the method
they may not be the technical or domain
experts however they are knowledgeable
enough to be able to have productive
conversations about the project being
done by the team tasks for the scrum
Master the scrum Master is a crucial
role and it is important for you to be
able to be clear about exactly how the
scrum Master serves the team
scrum Masters are servant leaders this
means that they put the team before
themselves and assist the team for
example they set up ensure that the
scrum ceremonies are effectively carried
out
they ensure that there is smooth flow of
information within and outside the team
and that there is a spirit of
collaboration in decision making and
problem solving
scrum Masters must make it their mission
to resolve issues that hinder team
progress
it doesn't matter what the nature of the
issue is a scrum Master needs to
mobilize the right resources within the
organization to resolve those issues in
a timely manner and escalate promptly if
that does not happen
we need to understand that in the short
duration of a Sprint even a few hours of
being stuck can make the difference
between a successful and unsuccessful
Sprint
scrum Masters protect the team they
ensure that the team is not Disturbed or
asked to deviate from their commitments
if pressure mounts due to unreasonable
expectations they will step in and push
back on the team's behalf
they will also play the role of
Peacemaker when conflict arises by
encouraging the parties to focus on the
issue discuss the issue with an open
mind and resolve the conflict
finally scrum Masters are the process
coaches of the team
they use their understanding of agile
methods and scrum in particular to guide
the team through the do's and don'ts of
scrum
they ensure that the team stays true to
the principles of Agile development
scrum Master roles scrum teams
before we discuss the role of a
developer on a scrum team let's talk
about the desirable characteristics of
scrum teams
they should be small and Nimble team
size should be no less than three and no
more than nine so that would be six plus
or minus three
exceptions are possible but uncommon
the small attribute makes the team
Nimble and improves productivity
it avoids the phenomenon Mike Cohn calls
social loafing and instead produces
focus on work
the team size should be just large
enough that the team members are able to
produce and showcase a significant
increment of work at the end of each
Sprint
after Sprint
self-sufficient and cross-functional
for example if a team needs user
interface development skills database
expertise and service expertise all of
those skills must be present on the team
ideally team members are generalizing
specialists team members should not only
be an expert or a specialist at one
aspect of the development effort but
should also have enough skills and
knowledge to fill in in other roles as
necessary for example if you are a UI
developer
you should be able to don the Hat of a
Services developer if needed
if a large team is to be split up into
smaller scrum teams scrum favors feature
teams over component teams
autonomous and self-organizing
teams choose for themselves how they are
going to organize and meet the goals of
the product owner
no one gets to dictate to the team how
to get their work done
the team decides in collaboration with
the product owner the project Direction
and the pros and cons of different
approaches
let's talk about some key decision
points or factors to consider when
assembling scrum teams
feature teams over component teams the
first issue is whether it's best to
align team members based on features or
components scrum favors feature teams
over component teams for example
it's best to avoid putting all of the UI
developers together and all of the API
or Services developers together why
because each feature or user story will
require both the UI and services or API
organizing based on components will
reduce the incentive to collaborate the
only reason component teams may be
justified would be if the components are
likely to be used by multiple other
teams
assemble the right people it's important
to get the right mix of people together
for the team the right level of
Technical and domain expertise teams
will naturally have both senior and
junior level developers this works
perfectly as there will be stuff that is
more appropriate for the junior
developers and stuff that is not also
one of the risks of a small team is that
the team may miss out on broader
perspective and dissenting views one way
to work around this is to deliberately
favor diversity in all aspects gender
ethnicity personality traits Etc it may
take some time for the team to advance
through the storming stage of teen
development and develop the trust
necessary to work effectively together
but it can be done once a team has been
formed it's best to preserve and assign
whole teams rather than individuals to
projects
it's best to avoid assigning team
members to multiple projects at the same
time
distributive team
a distributed team may be unavoidable
those based at the same geographical
location should be co-located in the
same team room
and Technology processes and ground
rules should be put in place to overcome
the disadvantages of all team members
not being co-located
plotting team size and productivity will
likely result in an s-curve you can see
here that a team can actually be too
small or too large Remember The Sweet
Spot is 6 plus or minus three
think of scrum as a lightweight
framework that utilizes principles and
practices that assist teams in
delivering working software in short
Cycles to the customer enabling rapid
feedback continuous Improvement and
quick response to change
it promotes delivering value as in
working software to the customer in an
incremental and iterative way
it is not a process or technique for
developing software rather it is a
framework within which various processes
techniques and practices are employed
in scrum the iterations that deliver
working software to the customer are
called sprints
in each iteration or sprint results in
potentially shippable software
this slide is a graphical representation
of an agile project using scrum
starting at the left you can see that
the product owner owns the product
backlog and in collaboration with the
team develops the user stories or
requirements for the project
the product backlog is prioritized with
the higher priority items occupying the
top of the product backlog
in collaboration with the product owner
the team decides how to group the user
stories into releases based on the
product roadmap
once the release planning has been
completed the user stories are then
selected for a Sprint
the duration of the Sprint is going to
be two to four weeks
once the Sprint backlog has been
determined the team then disaggregates
each user story into tasks
during each Sprint the user stories are
developed
as the code is written it is integrated
into the system and daily scrums are
held at the end of a Sprint there is a
Sprint review where the working software
is demonstrated and presented to the
customer for acceptance the team then
conducts a Sprint retrospective during
the retrospective the team looks at
primarily three things what went well
what did not go well and what should be
done differently going forward the
team's velocity is then updated as are
the information radiators which
transparently displayed the status and
progress of the project and then the
cycle repeats itself until the project
is complete
a Sprint is an iteration in scrum at the
beginning of a project the scrum team
determines the duration of Sprints for
the project most Sprints are going to be
two to four weeks in duration
factors affecting Sprint duration
include the stability of the product
backlog
once a Sprint has begun the duration is
never changed nor are any user stories
added or removed
therefore if many changes are expected a
shorter Sprint duration would be best
however if the product backlog is
relatively stable a longer Sprint
duration may be appropriate
overhead there are overhead costs
associated with each Sprint for example
every spint is going to have a Sprint
planning meeting a Sprint review and a
Sprint retrospective if a team has been
able to lower these overhead costs by
automated testing continuous integration
Etc these costs can be absorbed more
easily making shorter Sprints more
desirable
however if these overhead costs remain
high the team may need to use longer
duration sprints
a team may be tempted to extend the
duration of Sprints in an effort to hide
their inefficiencies remember
agile projects favor shorter duration
Sprints and it is the scrum Master's
responsibility to coach and Mentor the
team so it can reduce waste
irregularities and overuse and make the
Sprint shorter the goal of a Sprint is
to deliver working software at the
conclusion of each Sprint the team
should be able to deliver near
releasable or potentially shippable
software this is not easy especially for
an existing product with a lot of Legacy
features but it can be done with the
right technical practices and mature
development processes
once the Sprint duration has been
determined and the user stories for the
Sprint have been selected the duration
of the Sprint cannot be altered nor can
any user stories be added or removed the
Sprint will end at the appointed time
irrespective of whether the team has met
the Sprint goals or not
this allows for Effective continuous
Improvement if the team is unable to
deliver the working software as planned
the team will have to figure out why
that happened and then make changes to
improve going forward
the product owner may choose to cancel
or terminate a Sprint in specific
situations for example a significant
change in priorities or a mid-course
correction May render the current Sprint
backlog invalid
given that we are only talking about a
couple of weeks of work the cancellation
of a Sprint would be an extremely rare
event
a Sprint will begin with a Sprint
planning meeting and end with a Sprint
review in retrospective
there are three backlogs used in scrum
the product backlog the release backlog
and the Sprint backlog the product
backlog is the master container of all
the user stories for the project the
product backlog is continually pruned or
prioritized so that maximum value is
delivered to the customer
the release backlog is a subset of the
product backlog releases support the
product roadmap and each release is
populated with user stories necessary
for that release
log is a subset of the release backlog
and contains the user stories to be
developed in the Sprint
as we said the product backlog contains
the user stories for the entire project
and it is the responsibility of the
product owner user stories are features
functions or requirements that deliver
value to the customer
however the product backlog will also
have to contain technical or
non-functional user stories necessary
for the system to work properly
the product backlog may also include
risk or defect related user stories the
product owner is responsible for keeping
the product backlog current and up to
date this is accomplished by pruning the
backlog which is prioritizing and
re-prioritizing
product backlog must also be continually
groomed this is the process of adding
and removing user stories based on the
needs and desires of the customer
there are four scrum ceremonies the
Sprint planning meeting the daily scrum
the Sprint review and the Sprint
retrospective
let's take a detailed look at each of
these ceremonies
the Sprint planning meeting is time
boxed at two hours for each week of the
Sprint
if the Sprint is going to be two weeks
in duration then the time box will be
four hours if the Sprint is going to be
four weeks in duration then the time box
for the Sprint planning meeting will be
eight hours
it should be attended by the complete
scrum team including all roles
the most important aspects of this
meeting are the team's capacity and the
definition of done
there are two approaches to selecting
user stories for a Sprint
one is based on the velocity of the team
the other is commitment driven
team buy-in is critical and the goals of
the Sprint should be clearly understood
and the desired outcome should be
clearly articulated with the definition
of done then there's the daily scrum
the time box for the daily scrum is 15
minutes regardless of the duration of
the Sprint length the entire scrum team
including all roles should attend the
daily scrum
each development team member
individually answers three questions
what did I do yesterday
what am I going to do today and what are
my impediments
this is how the team members coordinate
their work and the scrum Master learns
of the impediments he or she should be
taking care of
the Sprint review takes place at the end
of the Sprint and is time boxed at one
hour for each week of the Sprint
so if the Sprint were four weeks in
duration the Sprint review meeting would
be four hours
it should be attended by the complete
scrum team including all roles plus any
other stakeholders who are interested in
project success
the purpose of the review is to
demonstrate working software and obtain
and assess feedback
feedback May range from Full acceptance
of the completed software to complete
rejection
the Sprint retrospective takes place
after the conclusion of the Sprint
review and is time boxed at 45 minutes
for each week of the Sprint
so if the Sprint has two weeks in
duration then the retrospective would be
one and a half hours in length
it should be attended by the complete
scrum team including all roles
however the product owner's attendance
is considered optional
during the retrospective the team
answers
four questions
what worked well
what did not work well
what should be done differently
and what still puzzles us
one or several problem detection
techniques may be used in the
retrospectives and this ceremony is a
vital part of continuous Improvement
at the conclusion of the retrospective
the team's velocity and the Project's
information radiators are updated
then the next Sprint's planning meeting
takes place and this cycle continues
until the project is complete the
definition of done is an important
artifact for a scrum team it is the
primary reporting mechanism for team
members and there may be a different
definition of done at various levels
definition of done for a feature or user
story
the definition of done for a Sprint and
the definition of done for a release
it's really just a checklist of
activities that add verifiable and
demonstrable value to the product
it's created by the scrum master in
consultation with the team
a sample list of the items for the
definition of done criteria is given
here
the story is fully implemented or code
completed as described automated unit
tests have been developed with at least
80 percent code coverage automated unit
tests and acceptance tests in the story
are passing
high priority test cases have been
automated and added to the regression
Suite
note this is only meant to be an example
each team's definition of done will vary
slightly depending on the maturity of
the team and the specific situation of
the team
the product team has taken up a new
project called WeatherMaster the team is
planning to move to scrum methodology
and this is an outline of its first
scrum meeting time boxed to 15 minutes
Rick is the scrum master of this meeting
where the team members discuss what they
did yesterday their plans for today and
the impediments they faced all team
members are standing up including Todd
who's joined the meeting via video chat
Rick holds the meeting near scrum board
Angela the product owner's absent Rick
reiterates that all discussions would be
parked until after the scrum meeting and
encourages his team to keep the meeting
short
people can chime in to resolve obstacles
hi team welcome to the Daily stand-up
meeting for the product team on Project
WeatherMaster
we are in Sprint 1 and today is the
second day
as we are planning to transition to
scrum methodology I hope you will find
this daily stand-up meeting helpful
in this meeting you will provide
information about what you did yesterday
what you plan to do today and what
challenges you faced
I think everyone's here let's start
I don't see Angela shouldn't she be here
I did add Angela as an optional attendee
to this meeting and since she hasn't
showed up we don't have to wait for her
Susan
scrum doesn't provide a specific yes or
no about the product owner's
participation in the daily scrum
the Po's primary role is to provide
Direction and clarify requirements and
priorities
since we don't always discuss those in
detail at this meeting the PO is not
required to be here
if the PLS want to attend they are
generally in listen only mode for the
duration of the meeting
they can use the information gathered
during the meeting for separate offline
conversations
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
what about Todd he works from his home
office right
Todd will be a part of the meeting
through video chat it is important that
we include every team member in the
meeting
hi Todd how are you
I'm fine thanks am I Audible
yes Todd team let's all stand up for the
meeting
[Music]
foreign
why don't you go first Aaron
yesterday I was working on creating the
mock objects to mask the database calls
from the unit tests
the difficulty with this approach is
that our server side logic is so
dependent on the metadata that writing a
true mock is a mammoth exercise
there are decisions that are taken
during run time based on the data some
of the stored procedure calls are also
made based on the values returned
through inline queries that are also
embedded in the code
I was debugging the code until about 9
pm
but for the life of me I couldn't figure
this out
Aaron could we request you to be concise
when you provide an update if you think
some of the details you described might
be interesting to others why don't you
write a Wiki page on it and share the
link
so getting back to your update did you
finish the task yesterday
no it turned out to be much more complex
than I had imagined I'll continue to
work on it today and see if I can figure
out an XML structure to mock the schema
and hard code some return values but I
am really stuck as far as the inline
queries are concerned
I know what you're talking about
there is a reason why the inline queries
are there in the code
this is mainly for performance reasons
when the overheads of making a procedure
called based on a metadata value and
then processing them sorry for the
interruption again guys this is a really
great conversation may I suggest we
write this issue in the parking lot
I'm not sure what you mean by that Rick
let me explain what Aaron just brought
up is a blocking issue team members
should bring these up during the daily
scrum so that everybody knows that one
of the team members is stuck however the
daily scrum is not necessarily the
meeting where solutions to every
obstacle can or should be found
it looks like Mary knows a thing or two
about the issue that Aaron has brought
up let's jot this down as a parking lot
topic this means the team can have
offline conversations after the daily
scrum to track it down
I'm also going to make a note that will
track the impediment Aaron faced daily
until it is removed you should let me
know if I can help in any way right
Aaron is there anything else you would
like to say no I am done thanks
yesterday I worked on developing the
Wizards for book order creation I'm
almost done today I need to write code
to handle some of the exception
scenarios before I can get them over to
Susan for testing that's it for me I
guess
did you forget to mention any
impediments not really an impediment at
present but I would like to mention that
my computer probably needs to be
upgraded with more RAM it has been slow
for the past few weeks
okay I wrote up some scenarios to test
the bulk order wizard I'm looking to get
my hands on the code as soon as Mary is
done today I'm also hoping to complete
the company order testing that has been
pending for a while
I'm okay for the moment but I do have
one question shouldn't we all be
updating the task board as we speak
we could it is up to you guys if you
think you want to do this during the
meeting if you asked my opinion we
should update the board as soon as we
are ready to move the tasks and not wait
for the meeting
this will ensure that the board is
always up to date and also that we use
the meeting time to focus on the
conversations
that's a great point Rick I can't see
the board very well from here anyway so
maybe we should find a way to create an
electronic version of it too at some
point
great Point Todd why don't you go next
with your updates
all right hey Rick would you like to
know about my work on the advertising
module first or the integration server
whatever the team decides is fine with
me remember this is really your meeting
and I'm only here to facilitate and
ensure we get the most out of this
meeting
foreign
[Music]
I guess I'll start with the integration
server I would like to inform everybody
that I managed to set up the integration
server that we can use as a Sandbox to
test the code before checking it in
Source control I'll send everybody a
link with some instructions and
credentials I have also started looking
at the stories for the advertising
module it looks like there are a lot of
open statements in the stores that I
don't really understand I guess I should
have been paying more attention during
the Sprint planning I really need to
have a conversation with Angela about
this that is my main impediment right
now I sent her an email but haven't
received a response yet
I don't have anything new to add today
I'm almost through with setting up our
project on the freeware tool that I
downloaded yesterday I'll show you guys
a demo in the meeting I set up later
today
I'll try to chase down some of these
parking lot items anything else before
we close the meeting
all right that's it for today have a
great day
do you have a moment to chat about the
inline queries real quick
the purpose of a scrum meeting is to
keep the team members updated and
resolve any impediments it's an ideal
way to kick start the day on a positive
note
the scrum Master reinforces the sense of
the self-managing team facilitates
communication between team members
brings the team's Focus back to what's
important and supports Improvement
so before we dive into the differences
between scrum and kanman let's have a
look at what exactly scrum is
scrum is a simple agile project
management framework that is used by
organizations to help teams collaborate
handle unpredictability and complex
projects or products while ensuring the
products delivered are of the highest
value
it describes a set of meetings tools and
roles that enable teams to work in sync
and help them structure themselves and
manage their work
scrum is one of those things that's
really easy to understand but very
difficult to master
and although scrum is seen to be used
generally by software development teams
its principles and themes are pretty
Universal and can be used with just
about all kinds of teamwork
with scrum teams are able to learn from
their experiences
what worked out what didn't and things
like that
they're also able to organize themselves
to handle their problems effectively and
basically improve themselves by
reflecting on them
so how does scrum work
here we have the first component the
product backlog
the product backlog consists of a list
of tasks that need to be completed so
that the goals of the stakeholders are
achieved
then the team decides what tasks from
the product backlog they want to take up
and deliver in a two to four week period
called Sprint
hence the name Sprint planning
next the tasks that were discussed in
the previous phase are added to the
Sprint backlog
this is a set of tasks which will be
focused on in the ongoing Sprint
following this the scrum team which is
usually five to nine members strong will
work on these tasks
now they also have regular scrum
meetings where they talk about their
victories the issues they face and what
they plan to do in the next 24 hours
and then they have the Sprint review
the Sprint review is a meeting during
which the team shows what they
accomplished during the Sprint
now during this time questions are asked
observations feedback and suggestions
are made
the product owner also gets feedback for
upcoming Sprints from stakeholders
they also have a Sprint retrospective
now during this session pass mistakes
potential issues and new ways to handle
them are identified
data from here is incorporated into the
new Sprint plan
the final step is increment
here a workable and usable output is
provided to the stakeholders
so now that we know how scrum Works
let's have a look at kanban
kanban comes from the Japanese word can
bam which literally means signboard
like scrum kanban is a popular agile
framework that is a visual system by
which the work can be managed with ease
as it progresses
kanban uses something known as the
kanban board to make these things
possible
with this you can easily identify
bottlenecks and then fix them cost
effectively at optimal speeds
the main focus with kanban is
transparency
since everything related to the tasks
are on the board
everyone can keep themselves updated
it also ensures the team's focus on
their current tasks until they're done
this limits the amount of work that's in
progress
so on the kanban board work is divided
into smaller more manageable pieces
the work that's needed to be done is
written on a note or card and placed on
a board
columns on the board help represent
where each item is
with respect to the workflow
now let's have a look at what these are
in detail
let's find out how kanban works
now the board consists of three major
components
that's the to-do list which represents
items that need to be completed
the ongoing column which represents
items that are being currently worked on
and the completed or the done column now
these represent tasks or items that have
already been completed
now although this is a physical
representation of the board several
organizations use software versions of
the board that replaces the sticky notes
with cards that can be moved from one
column to another as work progresses
now an example of such a software is
Trello
so if you want to learn more about
Trello you can check out the link I'll
be adding to the live chat in a moment
at this point you guys must have
realized how similar these two
Frameworks sound
so let's run through some more of their
similarities
let's find out how they are similar
firstly they both have principles of
lean and agile which means reduction of
waste and both of them are time boxed
and iterative approaches that enable
product delivery in an incremental
manner
both these Frameworks aim to reduce the
amount of work in progress
this forces the teams to ensure that
they focus on a smaller set of tasks
this also makes blockers and bottlenecks
a little more visible
in both cases the work is divided into
smaller more manageable units
both of these Frameworks use pull
scheduling now this means that products
are only Built based on demand rather
than forecasts
transparency plays a major role in both
these Frameworks by helping them Drive
process Improvement
and in both cases the release plan is
continuously optimized and finally both
these methods aim to deliver releasable
software often and earlier than expected
so now that we've reached Midway let me
ask you guys a question
do you guys use scrum or kanban in your
workplace or do you use this software
for personal reasons what exactly do you
use these for let me know in the live
chat
now let's have a look at how these two
Frameworks are different from one
another
firstly let's have a look at Cadence
Cadence refers to the amount of time in
a Sprint or before a release
so when it comes to scrum the entire
project is divided into time constrained
iterations that is into smaller
manageable units
but when it comes to kanban it's even
driven
the next criteria we're going to have a
look at
this release methodology
in scrum releases take place after each
Sprint which usually takes two to four
weeks to complete
for kanman leases take place in the form
of continuous delivery
they happen in such a way that changes
like new features configuration changes
bug fixes and experiments get to the
users in a safe quick and sustainable
manner
next up let's have a look at how changes
are addressed in both these Frameworks
in scrum no change can be made while
this print is in progress
once it's complete changes can be
considered in the Sprint plan and then
added to the Sprint backlog
with kanban changes can be made at any
time and incorporated into the workflow
now let's consider the metric that's
being measured
in scrum for planning and process
Improvement velocity which is the
measure of the work that can be
completed by a team in a Sprint is the
key metric
in kanban lead time is the key metric
this represents the period of time
between a new task's appearance in your
workflow and its final departure from
the system
next let's have a look at how teams work
in these Frameworks in scrum you need a
cross-functional team to achieve your
goals in a Sprint
in kanban cross-functional teams are
optional but specialized themes that
focus on particular aspects of the
workflow are required
now let's talk about new additions
in scrum just like handling changes you
can't add any items between a Sprint or
nitration
in kanban new items can be added to the
board as long as there is capacity
available for it
now let's have a look at the job roles
Within These Frameworks
scrum has three major job roles product
owner scrum master and scrumpteen
with kanban you don't have any specific
job roles
now let's talk about representation
or moreover let's talk about how data
can be represented
with scrum the Board needs to be reset
once a particular Sprint is complete
with kanban the board stays persistent
throughout the entirety of the project
and finally let's have a look at project
length
with scrum it's better suited for longer
projects
and with kanban projects that can be
completed in a shorter period of time
are better
so which one should you choose
now selecting from these two methods is
mainly based on the requirements of the
team
do you expect your project to be shorter
do you want to make changes at any time
you don't want to set up job specific
roles then kanban is the framework for
you
or do you want a long running project
with different job roles and involving
cross-functional teams
scrum is the answer for you
based on the differences we discussed in
the last topic you can make an informed
decision
now let's have a look at some of the
popular companies around the world that
employ both these Frameworks
some of the companies that have
successfully implemented scrum are
Facebook General electronics and Adobe
companies that have implemented kanban
are Siemens BBC and sap
if getting your learning started is half
the battle what if you could do that for
free visit skillup by simply learn click
on the link in the description to know
more
so as part of this tutorial we are going
to understand the typical interview
questions which would come across when
someone faces the interview for any of
the roles in the scrum
so question number one what is Scrum
so scrum is a framework that enables
team to work together
so with scrum teams can learn from
experiences
self-organize working on problems to
reflect on their victories and their
losses to improve
so this is a simple framework which will
provide a better ability and methodology
one can able to handle it better
so scrum is very well defined
articulated and this provides a better
insights and capabilities building
access is very easier and roles are well
defined
so Define the roles in scrum so what are
the typical roles we come across in
scrum
so one of the roles we come across is
product owner so product owner is
primarily responsible for maximizing the
ROI by determining the product features
prioritizing it into a list what needs
to be focused on for the next print and
constantly re-prioritizing and refining
it
so what happens is whenever we may
require to deliver it is very important
for us to have the requirements clear
what requirements needs to be fulfilled
to fulfill the requirements the products
what is produced should have specific
features and functionalities
so product owner will have the list of
features and functionalities which needs
to be created when product comes out as
a result of a project
so product owner owns this primary
responsible to ensure these list of
features are identified and those are
prioritized as required
so next role we can think of is Scrum
master who helps teams learn and apply
scrum to obtain business value
so scrum Master helps removing
impediments impediment is anything which
can stop things to flow smoothly so
protects them from interface and helps
the team to adopt a gel practices
now scrum is one of the methodologies
for agile approaches and practices now
remember the term agile itself is not a
practice it it refers to indicate that
move faster become flexible respond to
change be flexible now scrum methodology
especially scrum Master should
understand this Dynamics and ensure the
team understands this and scrum Master
should guide the team to adopt these
methodologies and ensure the results are
accomplished accordingly
so next row is Scrum team so scrum team
is a group of individuals who work
together to deliver the requirements of
the stakeholders so scrum team is
generally of the size like 5 plus or
minus two who are self-organizing so
various different capabilities the scrum
team members would have so each of these
capabilities complement to accomplish
the results required so question number
three what are the responsibilities of
this crumb theme
so scrum team is self-organizing as I
mentioned earlier so it is a
self-organizing team that has five to
seven members and the responsibilities
would include the development and
delivery of working products during each
Sprint now we are seeing the new
terminology Sprint so what is the
meaning of this print
now Sprint refers to an iteration a Time
boxed iteration which will have a
specific deliverables to be accomplished
as part of it so self-organizing team
takes that specific working piece what
needs to be delivered so that is a
Sprint backlog we call it as so from the
product backlog the features
functionalities which needs to be
delivered as part of this specific
iteration called Sprint time boxed
iteration and those Sprint backlog items
are delivered the output of the Sprint
would be the features what is been taken
is a working piece working product
so to demonstrate ownership and
transparency for work assigned to them
so they own it the entire thing assigned
to them there is there should be
ownership so ensuring the success of
daily scrum meeting by providing crisp
and correct information
so scrum has one event there are five
events basically so one of the events
which happens daily is daily scrum
meeting where the team comes with scrum
master so they would speak about what is
that they have accomplished from the
previous standup to till now is there
anything which is stopping them to move
forward
so giving the crisp updates a specific
summary updates so that scrum Master
understands the status so any specific
uh changes or any specific support which
are required scrum Master would discuss
separately with those individuals and
get it done so it should be minimum 15
minutes meeting when we say daily
stand-up meeting
so scrum team collaborate with each of
the team members they work together
under self-organize so next question the
differentiate between agile and scrum
now it is very essential to understand
the terminology's differences
so if we just end up with looking at a
wrong understanding of each of the
terminologies then explaining will
become difficult so what does it mean by
agile and what it is when it comes to
the terminology called scrum the term
agile refers to ability to move quickly
and easily by becoming more flexible and
adaptable this is what the meaning which
gets associated with the term agile so
many times I have seen people answering
agile is a methodology AJR is a
iterative and increment methodology and
also I think when you search through the
popular search engines you may come
across that which is wrong so agile is
the terminology which is used to state
to move quickly and easily by becoming
more flexible and adaptable this we
should keep in mind so if that our
question may be like what are agile
methodologies
then you can come across like one of the
agile methodologies scrum and you can go
on on various different methodologies
what we have
so scrum is an agile methodology
right the term scrum is the name given
to the agile metal methodology which
enables organization to become agile
right so to become agile obviously there
are various methodologies scrum is very
popular so that is the main difference
so further if you look at agile
Manifesto on 12 principles which acts as
guidelines to become a child so there is
something called a gel Manifesto Four
Points
clearly articulates what needs to be
focused on to become agile and that
support that is supported through the 12
principles which guides
so scrum is used in projects where
requirements are constantly changing
means I want to become agile so I adopt
scrum so this definitely
has to align to Agile Manifesto and take
the guidelines whatever is mentioned in
12 principles of agile Manifesto then
looking at a leadership perspective
roles perspective so Manifesto mentions
the required collaboration interactions
to become a child
whereas scrum defines the roles like the
scrum Master the product owner the
self-organizing teams which is
cross-functional self-organizing team
so these are the main three roles which
scrum defines now generally when we say
projects we come across the role like
project manager so do we see uh the such
project managers in scrum answer is no
because the scrum master who engages
with Team regularly
more than management they focus on doing
facilitating role to the scrum teams so
that things can be delivered the way it
is required and more flexibility is
given to the team to take the calls to
accomplish the results so scrum Master
facilitates whereas the product owner as
I mentioned earlier looks at the product
backlog and prioritizes and provides
what are the features functionalities
needs to be created in the next
iterations
So speaking about flexibility definitely
agile Manifesto mentions the required
focus on working software and focusing
on changes
so that that's the focus the direction
what it provides so scrum approaches
enables teams to react to changes
quickly Jessica methodology is made such
a way the team understanding that can
able to react and those changes and
modifications are made visible to the
team so delivery perspective Manifesto
provides necessary guidelines on
frequent delivery of product or software
so scrum with time boxed iterations
called sprints builds delivered to the
users regularly and half-held agile
principles that is very important so
delivery here is as per the user's
requirement as per the customer
requirements because customer when we
want to become a child customer has to
involve very closely stakeholder has to
collaborate without that you cannot
become a jack
so next point is about collaboration
a jail Manifesto stresses on individual
interactions and customer collaborations
So based on this if you look at in the
scrum how are they demonstrating this so
there are various events which happens
in scrum so as I mentioned earlier we
have daily stand-up meetings and other
scrum events like Sprint rest
retrospective Sprint reviews Daily
Standard meetings which happens like
Sprint planning which happens regularly
so it becomes a reason for collaboration
and everyone to discuss and take the
call so question number five what are
the main artifacts of this chrome
process Now product backlog
so which consists of list of new
features
changes
which are looking organization is
looking for uh to bring into the
existing features changes to the
existing features bug fixes changes to
the infrastructure and several other
activities to ensure a particular
outcome so product backlog
so then we can speak about Sprint
backlog a subset of product backlog
so the Sprint backlog contains tasks
that the team aims to complete to
satisfy the Sprint's goals so set off
product backlog things are taken put
into Sprint backlog and those are the
features which are supposed to be
produced as a result as part of that
particular Sprint the team first
identifies tasks from the product
backlog that need to be delivered to
achieve a goal so these tasks are then
added to the Sprint backlog
so the team first identifies tasks from
product backlog
as per the priorities the list which is
prioritized in the product backlog that
is taken put into Sprint backlog and
then those are delivered
so next you can think about product
increment the product increment is the
combination of all product backlog tasks
completed in the Sprint and the value of
the increments of previous prints the
outcome should be in the usable
condition even if the product owner
doesn't decide to release it it is very
important each of the increments which
comes out
so needs to fulfill this
now question number six how are the
product and Sprint backlog different
from one another product backlog versus
Sprint backlog let us see few
differences
so product backlog is the list of items
that needs to be completed for
developing the product which is the list
of all the features functionality
Consolidated one
but a Sprint backlog is a list of items
to be completed during each Sprint which
are taken from product backlog
the backlog when it comes to product
backlog the backlog is collected from
the customer by product owner and
assigned to the team whereas
in Sprint backlog the teams collects the
backlog from the product owner and sets
up the time frame for the Sprint
so product backlog is specific to end
goal ultimate objective whereas Sprint
backlog is pretty specific to that
Sprint specific iteration called Sprint
in scrum
what is that we are going to produce as
part of it
product backlog is based on customer
Vision whereas Sprint backlog will vary
based on the product Vision defined by
product owner so priorities list you
take from the product backlog
so product backlog is independent of
Sprint backlog whereas Sprint backlog is
dependent on product backlog region we
know already I explained so this is this
the prioritized list of backlogs we take
from product backlog and create this uh
specific product as part of Sprint which
become Sprint backlog
so product backlog refers to until the
project is complete the product owner
maintains the product backlog
for a Sprint backlog when it comes to
Sprint backlog each news prints as
backlogs added by the team as each
prints are initiated so next question
who is the scrum master and what does he
or she do
so a scrum Master promotes and supports
the adoption of scrum in the team scrum
Master helps everyone to understand the
theory practices rules and values in the
scrum
is playing the role of facilitation
enablement
right so scum Master ensures the team
follows Chrome values principles and
practices
remorse blockages that may hamper the
progress of the project
protects the team from being distracted
ensuring the team delivers value during
every Sprint
so next question what happens in Daily
stand-up sessions so daily stand-up
sessions are the discussion which are
done daily
that takes place under usually 15
minutes in duration the objective is to
understand what went well what tasks are
completed from the last stand-up session
what tasks are pending and the obstacles
the team was facing
if at all any specific task is not
accomplished for certain reasons so what
are stopping them stopping the team to
accomplish that that needs to be made
visible
so that separate meeting can be held to
discuss on that and do the necessary
Corrections by taking proper actions
so the objective of this daily stand-up
meeting is to understand the overall
scope and status of the project
further individual discussion can be
taken up after the daily stand-up
sessions
as I mentioned earlier if at all if you
find something is not accomplished as
per the plan now how do we ensure that
is corrected and why is it happening is
there anything any support is required
by the team to focus on that so
something like that can be checked on
question number nine what is Scrum ban
so scrum ban is a development
methodology that is a combination of
scrum and kanban
so this can be used to meet the needs of
the team that aims to minimize the
batching of work and to adopt a
pull-based system
so kanban is called as pool base system
so which actually helps in terms of
visualizing what work is in progress and
since it is a visualized visualized
system it is visible to everyone
so it works in terms of making people
become conscious to take that work and
get it closed quickly so it's also
called pool system because work is
pulled from that particular list
so in this kanban approach or
methodology or thought is applied in
scrum we call it as crumba so
combination of this definitely helps in
terms of making that entire Journey
successful and supports the scrum
methodology
so scrum burn includes the structure of
scrum along with the flexibility and
visualization of kanban
so scrumban is used by the teams that
need to be
structure of scrum that has the
structure of scrum and the flexibility
of a flow based method
like on one
so question number 10 what is print 0
and Spike so the term Sprint 0 refers to
the short amount of effort put for
creation of vision a rough skeleton of
the product backlog so now we do this
whenever we need to understand certain
things how things looks like to get
certain insights so this also includes
Insight towards estimating the release
of products so you get some Vision it
gives some clarity right so this Sprint
0 are required to create project
skeleton alongside research spikes
keeping minimal design
develop a small number of stories
completely have low velocity and be
lightweight
So speaking about this Spike so spike is
set off activities used in extreme
programming I think this was introduced
there in extreme programming that is one
of the agile methodologies
so involving research design
investigation making proof of Concepts
Etc
so the objective of spike is to reduce
the risk of technical approach by
gaining knowledge which helps
understanding requirements and to
improve reliability so more aware we are
more clarity we have I think putting
step further will become easier so
informed decisions you can take so next
question what is Scrum of scrumps
now scrum of scrums is a terminology
used for scaled agile techniques which
is required to control and collaborate
with multiple scrum teams
so when will we come across the need for
collaborating between multiple scrum
teams so these are the scenarios where
organization has a complex structure is
complex in nature where you may require
to handle them together all of them
together for accomplishing the common
objective for business various crumb
teams you would have so scrum of scrum
helps in terms of
better collaboration and handle them
easily or better way better control it
is best used in the situations where
teams are working together on complex
assignments just visualizing the system
various different deliverables which are
not a simple deliverables which we can
do with the simple scrum team
instead we have various different
deliverables which needs to be made and
Dynamics are too complex
so bigger projects then scrum of scrum
approaches can be taken so scaling the
agile methodology to that level
so it is used to establish the required
transparency
collaboration adaption adoption to the
required scale to ensure the products
can be developed and delivered so
whatever the products are delivered
whatever we consider to be delivered so
those needs to
focus on the business objectives which
is very essential
so what is user story mapping
so user story mapping represents and
arranges user stories
that help with understanding the
system's functionalities the system's
backlog planning releases and providing
value to the customers so first of all
we write user stories to understand the
required features functionality in their
user perspective
now if we map those user stories which
use a story link to other user story
which functionality links to the
functionality determining that will
become easier
so now a user story Maps arranges user
story based on the priority along the
horizontal axis on the vertical axis
they are represented based on increasing
level of sophistications
so this will help in terms of handling
in a regular flow in a specific flow not
regular flow specific flow so that
things can be done in order with full
clarity so question number 13 what
happens in Sprint retrospective so after
this print review
so Sprint completes so Sprint away
happens
the Sprint retrospective is done so
during this meeting
the Lessons Learned what went well what
mistakes we did
what were the issues
so is there any new way of doing things
so all these are discussed so that these
necessary Corrections can be considered
in the upcoming iterations the Sprints
so data from here is incorporated when
planning the new Sprint so the learning
what you had you are going to collect it
what went well what went wrong what was
supposed to be the best approach and how
did we approach it is there any other
way of doing it so these are discussed
and very essential to do it at the end
of completion of each of the Sprints
review
question number 14 what is empirical
process control in scrum
so empiricism refers to work based on
facts experiences evidences observations
and experimentation
so empirical process control is
established and followed in scrum
ensuring project progress and project
interpretation is based on facts of
observation so actual facts and figure
is very important any decisions what we
make any uh progression what we make
should be always based on on ground
facts and actual pictures we should not
debate from it
so these rely on transparency
observation adoption obviously when
you're working on the data on ground
reality so you are working on the actual
one it is transparent it is on the
observed data
the mindset of the team and the shift
required in thought process and culture
are very essential to accomplish the
agility required by organization
so mindset of the team is very essential
and Adoption of process compliance to
the process the culture the behavior
obviously plays a very important role
when
you do something within the organization
so that needs to be done as per the need
which should complement to the business
objectives
very important and that should be based
on facts not on some thoughts or
assumptions or ideas
so next question is what are some
drawbacks of using scrum so scrum
requires individuals who have experience
without whom the project risks will have
a risk of failure
so one does not have a capability
difficult scrum request team to be
collaborative and committed
so well people collaborating individuals
collaborating itself is a big challenge
in many organizations so bringing this
into the place is very important when
you want to adopt scrum
so scrum requires teams to be
collaborative and committed to ensure
the required results they should work
together
and also they should collaborate with
customers stakeholders
the less experienced scrum Master can
cause the failure of the project
so be careful
scrum Master is the one who is
facilitator we should understand this
who enable the scrum teams who ensure
scrum teams goes the way we need them to
work if scrum Master doesn't understand
his Dynamics does not have the clarity
on this obviously the he or she cannot
enable to team to become that
if tasks are not well defined the
project can have any inaccuracies
Chrome works better for smaller projects
and would be difficult to scale to large
complex projects that's where we are
discussing on a few questions before
this scrum off scrum we're discussing
about when it becomes a complex project
which those needs to be handled together
which will become complex so next
question is what are the skills of a
scrum master so a strong understanding
of scrum and agile concept
scrum Master should have fine-tuned
organizational skills so when scrum
Master is working with self-organizing
team with various different capabilities
so unless the organization skills
interpersonal skills if scrum Master
does not have working with them will
become difficult
so scum Master should be familiar with
technology that the team uses basic
understanding of that how it works the
Dynamics associated with that and scrum
Master should have an ability to coach
and teach the team to follow scrum and
its methodologies
and very clear about the terminologies
artifacts and all the events what
happens so scrum Master should have an
ability to handle conflicts and resolve
them quickly so conflict is a scenario
which would happen for various different
reasons
however when conflict occurs
the scrum Master should not shy away
from it own it to resolve in the
interest of the project whatever is
being done it is very important
scrum master has to be a servant leader
so it is not like I'm a specific manager
or leader of certain kind and I am doing
this with certain way no I am actually
facilitating I am guiding I am showing
certain direction
to the organization so that access to
the team when I say organization is
speaking about scrum team so that they
are unable to take up the specific
project and accomplish the results
accordingly
question number 17
how can
Discord be dealt within the scrum team
now the root cause of the issue need to
be identified an interest complete
ownership needs to be established when
you deal with this
and try to diffuse the disagreements so
emphasizing on the focus area that
complements the project
so here when we take up any of the
discussions any of the
opportunities or any actions what we
take everything should be revolving
around objective of ultimate objective
of whatever we are doing
so when we need to resolve something
when we get into the root causes always
it helps to look at the actions in terms
of eliminating those causes so once the
causes are eliminated it is quite
obvious you can able to deal with it and
address it with easily with the right
set of actions
so emphasis on Focus areas that
complements the project in the sense
that should be the ultimate Direction
not my individual interest not that
individual interest I favor this person
I favor that person that's not to be the
case
so favoring this solution or favoring
that solution I'm okay with this
particular technology I'm very happy
with this technology not such thoughts
it is the direction what you said I
should move things in that direction so
to establish a common understanding and
to guide the team to the direction
performing continuous monitoring and
providing complete visibility very very
important so next question what is a
user story
so user stories are an agile software
development project management tools
it provides the team with simple natural
language explanations of one or more
features written from the end user's
perspective
now for example Armor account holder in
a bank
so first what is the facility a bank
could give to
account holders there is ATM banking
there is net banking there is Mobile
Banking and there is over the counter
now when bank is working on creating
certain specific features or specific
mobile app to the account holders now
what are the things user needs that
needs to be visualized now if I say the
role here is account holder as a account
holder I want to
download the statements of every month
as a account holder I want to download
the statements every month this is what
my requirement is how will you
facilitate this this will provide the
insight to words
how
the bank what are the features and
functionalities and how this
requirements are can be fulfilled by the
bank and what features functionality the
particular mobile app should have so
that
account holder can download the
statements so user stories will provide
that insights whatever users so account
holder is not just an user here there
are many users when it comes to mobile
app of a bank
we have people who monitor it manage it
would develop it
so they need to have a Clarity on what
exactly they need and that needs to be
written
as part of user storage what features
functionality can be easily determined
out of it
so a user story does not go into detail
it just mentions as I give an example it
just mentions how a certain type of work
will bring value to the end user the end
user in this case could be in external
end users or even internal customers or
colleagues within the organization so if
I'm an organization I produce an HR
application I create an HR application
for claim processing which I don't have
till today
so that is for internal users in the
bank example I'm speaking about external
customers
so user stories also form the building
blocks of agile framework like epics and
initiatives
these help ensure that the teamwork to
the goals of the organization through
epic Sun initiatives so further the
requirements for making the user story
is a reality or added later after
discussing with the team so to write a
user story The involvement of the team
members are very essential they should
discuss and come out and agree yes this
is the features functionality which
should be there
user stories are recorded on Post-it
notes index cards or project management
software whatever is visible and
whatever is available there next
question
how are those stories epics and tasks
different so if the stories provides the
team with simple explanation of business
requirements created from the end user
perspective as we saw the few examples
in the previous questions epics
are the collection of related user
stories they're usually large and
complex so these epics are created with
specific objectives in mind and user
stories are grouped so that will form an
epic whereas task refers to the one
which are used to track work so they are
used to further broken down
from the user stories so there's a
smallest unit in the scrum used to track
work a person or a team or two people
usually work on the tasks so these tasks
are these through this task I think the
features functionality what are required
to be accomplished are done so question
number 20
what is Sprint now as I mentioned
earlier in the earlier question number
four
so Sprint is the terminology used in the
scrum I think we explained various
different concepts as we went through
so Sprint is a terminology is used in
scrum which refers to time boxed
iterations so we understood what is this
iterations in scrum approaches when we
are going through that the creation of
specific modular feature which is part
of a product is done during the Sprint
the duration of Sprint varies between a
week or two so means it's a short
duration simple few features
functionalities are taken and created so
what is velocity
so velocity is the metric used in scrum
that is a measurement of
the amount of work that is completed by
team during the Sprint
so this is help to measure how how
things are moving how fast are they are
moving it refers to the number of user
stories completed in single Sprint
so this speaks about that speed so or
velocity velocity uh how faster we are
going how slower we are going this helps
to vary the variations we can do in that
velocity uh depending on what business
need
so what are the responsibilities of a
product owner
so product owner Define the vision of
the project
they anticipate the needs
of the customer and to create
appropriate user stories so they don't
write user stories as such they
definitely have a set of people who
should get involved the team
to write the user stories lot of
discussion has to happen brainstorming
has to happen to write user stories but
product owner is accountable
so product owner has to evaluate the
progress of the Project based on this
backlog what project or product owner
has
and has stabilized in for all product
related questions the team may have
certain questions there's Sprints as the
Sprint progresses the scrum team may
have certain questions clarification
relating to the user stories those needs
to be clarified
what is burn up and burn down charts so
generally when we say chart it is a
graphical representation so burn up
chart is a tool that is used to track
the amount of work that has been
completed so it is a bar chart the
amount of work completed the height of
the bar keeps increasing in burn up
chart based on what is completed
which will show the total amount of work
the need to be done for a Sprint or a
project
so it is it is a bar chart where each of
the bars keeps increasing in its height
as number of things get delivered
increases
so burn down charts typically again a
graphical representation a bar chart
so what is pending to be delivered it
shows that now initially you will have a
bigger bar and as the project progresses
the height of the bars reduces
indicating what is that is pending for
deliverables it is a representation of
how fast the team is working through the
user stories it helps you to understand
that
so it shows total effort against the
amount of work for each iterations
which is helpful for a to see to that
what is spending to complete question 24
how is estimation in the scrum project
done
so the estimation of user stories is
done based on its difficulty
a particular scale in which which is
used to assess the difficulty of user
stories set analyze how difficult or
easy is that some of the scales which
are used like numeric sizing one to ten
t-shirt sizing like s ml Excel Fibonacci
series or dog breeds based on their
value so many such approaches are taken
what are some risks in scrum and how are
they handled
so first of all we should know what is
risk so some types of risk in scrum are
related to budget people
Sprint
product knowledge and capability
now when we say budget risk of uh
increase exceeding that allocated budget
taking more looking for more variations
I estimated for X it is going like the X
Plus Delta X so can we control it we
need to look at that so you need to
assess that risk when what possibilities
the cost can escalate people related
like team members need to be of
appropriate skills and capabilities if
they lack that obviously
difficult it's not about just skills and
capabilities the culture the behavior
the attitude
the energy
the Synergy that collaboration what
people will have then Sprint related in
terms of duration and deliverables
exceeding the duration
addition of scope to that Sprint in
between so that challenges
that difficulties
so product referring to user stories and
epics having ill-defined user stories
interprex not properly articulated there
is no proper visualization when you look
at that user story not understanding so
nobody is explaining it correctly
so then uh knowledge and capabilities so
it is not just related to the people
here it's a entire system everyone was
who is involved with the specific
resource with its capability it can be
technology capabilities also so when I
say risk it basically involves
identification assessment analysis and
defining risk response plans and
implementing them
now
when I say assess assessing the risks
should be qualitative as well as
quantitative
so depending on the impact and
probability of a risk if it is high
impact risk obviously you are required
to do both qualitative and quantitative
if a simple one with a very less impact
you can take the call accordingly to
what extent you may require to analyze
and have the response plans for it so
once you have implemented or defined and
implemented the response plans quite
obviously should keep monitoring it and
manage the risks the risk impacts and
probabilities may vary as the project
progresses so we may require to keep
assessing the identified risk and keep
identifying the new risks as you as we
progress in the project
so these are done on a continual basis
right from starting of the projectile
completion the reason I told it is
essential to understand that the impact
of the risk is based on the proximity of
actual occurrence of the risk
now for example if you start uh working
on something nothing is delivered at the
at the moment
now if specific risk of people are
people not available
our customer is not involved initial
stage very initial stage so risk impact
is accordingly
project would delay in entirety or
requirement is not very clear it is
delaying something of that sort of
impact you will have now as the project
progresses almost like 50 of the project
complete now the there is some
challenges or risk associated with
issues are occurring related to
customers involvement
now you are made of project so again you
will have a different kind of impact 50
is delivered now you need to progress
because active involvement of
stakeholders including customer is very
important when you are becoming a child
so when that is not happening as an
example I'm taking the involvement of
customers the collaboration part of it
so that is not happening now here the
impact level is not equal to the impact
level when when this happens in the
starting of the project same type of
risk what we are assessing
so that is the reason each of the risks
you should keep assessing the identified
one keep assessing as the project
progresses and check on is there any new
risk is introduced as the project is
progressing
so next question what are some popular
tools used in scrum
so these are the list so you can think
of gtab Soho Trello jira software yodex
where is a version one so now what I am
saying is
these are the tools technology tools
so when we say tools we cannot just
limit our thought to technology tools so
what exactly this tool does what are the
techniques used that we need to be very
clear
right The Matrix what is measured and
methodology of measuring it and what
processes are used what steps are used
so what needs to be used
so unless we are clear relating to
specific type of project usage of these
tools may not make any sense you cannot
even implement or customize this for the
requirement what you are trying to
accomplish so you be clear about it when
you're selecting the tool so 27 how does
scrum Master track Sprint progress
so we have various different event which
happens in scrum like daily scrum
meetings scrum retrospective scrum
planning scrum review
and checking on the defects which are
escaped density of the defects
burn down
uh Sprint burn down velocity so so
checking all of this
provides the better insight to scrum
master so that tracking the progress of
the Sprint will become easier
so and how to deal with the scope creep
now before we understand the dealing
with scope trip we need to understand
what is scope creep
so the term scope creep refers to the
change which is uncontrolled and added
without checking the impact on the
constraints like scope time costs
now what happens is you will be doing
certain delivering certain features
now you are forced or you are influenced
or without your knowledge some
additional things are put in place so
which may impact later it may add value
it may not add value later doesn't
matter but it may lead in terms of
impact your cost time and schedules
which is unexplained
and that extra effort what you have put
in extra cost what you are put in uh
will become like uh right not recognized
by customers and you will not get
anything paid for it so scope to avoid
the scope creep to deal with it one has
to ensure close monitoring of Works
being done on day-to-day basis because
scope creep can happen through team
members influencing team members are
influenced by consumer because of that
it may happen
so understanding communicating the
vision to the team for ensuring the
alignment so the team is very sensitive
about that changes what is happening
then capturing reviewing the project
requirements regularly against what is
delivered
to emphasize
to the team and customer about the
requirement signed off so that someone
will not comment
uh influence you or make that additional
things to be delivered they need not
push you right ensuring any change
introduced to go through change control
so no changes
without any proper approval by the
authorities so that only those what is
required to be implemented is
implemented and that is done formally
through the formal change request
so avoiding gold plating so it is with
different thought process when we say
gold plating so we were doing the
projects are trying to add certain
things into the scope to please the
customer as an example doing something
additional providing some additional
features and functionality for which we
are not paid so scope creep is not a
terminology used for it but gold plating
is the term used but however since it is
an additional scoping so we're just
added here
so don't say that when the moment scope
creep we says that is not gold plating
gold plating is a different direction so
just to explain you
along with scope creep what else would
happen to where the additional
deliverables would come in which is gold
plating so question 29 what is MVP and
MMP which means minimum viable product
and minimal marketing product so now
minimum viable product is a concept of
Lean Startup which stresses upon the
impact of learning while performing
product development so this allows one
to test and understand the idea by
getting exposed to the initial version
of the product for Target customers and
users so to accomplish this one has to
collect all the required relevant data
and learn from the collected data so the
thought behind MVP is to produce a
product to provide access to the users
and to observe how the product is used
perceived and understood
this will also provide more insight
towards what the customers or users
needs are
so when it comes to minimal marketable
product
this refers to the description of the
product which will have a minimal number
of features that addresses the
requirements of the users
MMP would help also the organization
reduce the time to Market because you
have the clarity what is that we may
require to provide now question number
30 what does DOD means definition of
done right so DOD refers to the
collection of deliverables
which includes written quotes comments
on coding unit tests integration testing
design documents release notes
Etc
this would add variable and
demonstratable values to the project
development
so devote is very helpful to scrum while
identifying the deliverables to achieve
the objectives of project for the stated
reasonable
so defining the steps required to
deliver the iterations the usage of
appropriate tool like burn down to make
the process more effective
ensuring on-time feedback throughout the
Project Life Cycle
ensuring the walkthrough of the product
backlog items are done and understood
correctly so then creation of checklists
for product backlog item
ensuring the devote is defined to become
task oriented involving the product
owner for reviewing during this print
and Sprint retrospective that is about
DOD the next question how can a scrum
Master be a servant leader it's a very
important thing to understand
so what is the meaning of the servant
leader the term servant leader mainly
stresses on service orientation which a
leader should demonstrate
so today we say every organization is
service organization
even an organization who is producing
car if there is a service orientation
they cannot sell
more stresses on being service
orientation the scrum Master needs to be
facilitator a guide a mentor Etc
this helps the team have increased
involvement and empowerment so now
question number 32 how can one
coordinate within multiple teams so one
of the most common approaches for this
is Scrum of scrums meeting so where
members representing each scrum team
discusses the progress
performance issues risk Etc together
this is complex structure what you're
speaking about
the frequency of these meetings must be
predefined well articulated well defined
generalist scrum Master would represent
the particular scrum team on behalf of
that scrum team they would go and
represent the meeting represent in the
meeting
besides having a chief scrum master
who's responsible is coordination and
collaboration among all scrubs or
facilitates these meetings thank you
guys with that we have reached the end
of the scrum
first video by simply learn I hope you
have
you have native and helpful thank you
for watching stay tuned for more from
Simply learn
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here